Alice: 火小一点
Alice: Lower the heat a bit.
Tasha:  火已经很小了
Tasha: The heat is already very low.
Alice: 你锅里是不是有油
Alice: Is there oil in your pan?
Alice: 哎不对
Alice: Oh no, wait.
Alice: 有水
Alice: It's water.
Tasha:  没有我已经把水抽干了
Tasha: No, I've already drained the water.
Lucia: 这锅昨天是不是用过呀
Lucia: Was this pan used yesterday?
Tasha:  我靠这锅怎么这么倒
Tasha: Damn, why is this pan so...
Tasha:  倒热怎么这么快
Tasha: It heats up so quickly.
Alice: 它比较薄
Alice: It's thinner.
Tasha:  拿一个那个小小小碟子来呗
Tasha: Get a small plate, please.
Tasha:  放这些饼
Tasha: To put these pancakes.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 露西亚你就不用帮我热了吧
Alice: Lucia, you don't need to heat it for me.
Alice: 倒直接倒就行了
Alice: Just pour it directly.
Alice: 给你
Alice: Here you go.
Alice: 笑死了这个这个
Alice: This is hilarious, this...
Alice: 手机拍的好整齐你看
Alice: The phone took such neat pictures, look.
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 像开会一样
Alice: Like a meeting.
Tasha:  开会上交手机
Tasha: Hand in phones at the meeting.
Lucia: 手机开会
Lucia: Phone meeting.
Tasha:  也不知道熟了没
Tasha: I don't know if it's cooked.
Tasha:  外面都糊了
Tasha: It's burnt on the outside.
Lucia: 啊sorry
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
Alice: 没
Alice: It's fine.
Alice: 这太短了时间
Alice: It's too short a time.
Tasha:  那只能用小火煎了
Tasha: Then we can only fry it on low heat.
Tasha:  看看不清了都没关系
Tasha: It's fine if it's unclear.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: No worries.
Alice: 你看这里面还爆浆呢
Alice: Look, it's still oozing inside.
Lucia: 这这这这瓶昨天没开过吗
Lucia: Was this bottle not opened yesterday?
Alice: 当然没熟
Alice: Of course it's not cooked.
Lucia: 你昨天没有开牛奶吗
Lucia: Didn't you open a bottle of milk yesterday?
Lucia: 应该开过一瓶吧
Lucia: Should have opened one.
Lucia: 先把开的那瓶喝了
Lucia: Finish the opened one first.
Alice: 看里面都不熟呢
Alice: Look, it's still not cooked inside.
Tasha:  外面都已经这么黑了
Tasha: It's already so dark outside.
Alice: 油一点点大哈
Alice: Just a little bit more oil.
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈
Alice: Ha.
Alice: 太厚了没关系没关系
Alice: It's too thick, but it's fine, it's fine.
Alice: 把那个外面面的那个丢掉就行
Alice: Just throw away the outer layer, it's okay.
Tasha:  OK第一个饼先给杨老板吃
Tasha: OK, let's give the first pancake to Jake.
Tasha:  我这个锅怎么回事
Tasha: What's up with this pan?
Tasha:  太可怕了
Tasha: It's terrifying.
Alice: 你要不给弄开吧好
Alice: Maybe you should just open it up.
Tasha:  好你看看熟了没
Tasha: Okay, check if it's done.
Alice: 勉强
Alice: Barely.
Lucia: 奥
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 我怎么每次开门都会掉点东西下来啊
Lucia: Why do I always drop something every time I open the door?
Tasha:  没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha:  我来把这个也也也剪开
Tasha: I'll cut this open too.
Lucia: 你放这了呀
Lucia: You put it here?
Lucia: 我可以用一下另一个灶吗
Lucia: Can I use the other stove?
Tasha:  要要用微波炉
Tasha: You need to use the microwave.
Tasha:  呃呃好吧
Tasha: Uh, okay.
Tasha:  这个也可以了
Tasha: This one is done too.
Lucia: 微波炉打吗
Lucia: Microwave it?
Lucia: 微波炉打不知道能不能打的透
Lucia: I don't know if it will cook through in the microwave.
Lucia: 而且没事就放在这吧
Lucia: Anyway, just leave it here.
Lucia: 然后大家再倒出来就好
Lucia: Then everyone can just pour it out later.
Tasha:  啊这个锅太可怕了
Tasha: Ah, this pan is terrifying.
Lucia: 哎这个灶台
Lucia: Hey, this stove.
Alice: 露西亚你准备的是几个人的牛奶
Alice: Lucia, how many people's milk did you prepare?
Lucia: 呃没事我们可以随便倒哈哈
Lucia: Uh, it's okay, we can just pour it freely, haha.
Alice: 啊因为我想喝凉的
Alice: Ah, because I want to drink it cold.
Lucia: 你想喝凉的
Lucia: You want to drink it cold?
Lucia: 呃有还有
Lucia: Uh, there's more.
Alice: 啊对
Alice: Ah, right.
Alice: 就是不用算我的量就可以了
Alice: Just don't include my portion.
Lucia: 没事那就如果多了的话
Lucia: No problem, if there's too much,
Lucia: 大家一会多喝一点就好了哈哈
Lucia: everyone can just drink more later, haha.
Alice: 啊好
Alice: Ah, okay.
Alice: 可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 就是那个那个已经打开的我也没倒完
Lucia: So that one that’s already opened, I haven't finished pouring it yet.
Lucia: 然后假如你不够喝
Lucia: And if you don't have enough to drink,
Lucia: 你也可以打开那个新的
Lucia: you can open the new one too.
Alice: 啊不用谢谢
Alice: Ah, no need, thank you.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: No worries, no worries.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Lucia: 哦这个OK
Lucia: Oh, this is OK.
Lucia: 咦
Lucia: Huh?
Alice: 这个我自己倒吧
Alice: I'll pour this myself.
Lucia: 这个火太大了
Lucia: The flame is too high.
Lucia: 啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 然后我看看
Lucia: Then let me see.
Lucia: 我们牛奶应该是要用杯子
Lucia: We should use cups for the milk.
Lucia: 我把剩下这几杯子都洗了
Lucia: I'll wash the remaining cups.
Alice: 我直接用碗了
Alice: I'll just use a bowl.
Lucia: 也可以哈哈
Lucia: That works too, haha.
Lucia: 这个任君选择
Lucia: It's up to you.
Lucia: 23234 那我们剩下有 4个
Lucia: 23234, so we have 4 left.
Lucia: 四个人的话
Lucia: If there are four of us,
Alice: 给外国人一点震撼
Alice: Let's give the foreigners a shock.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 雨轩你要单喝纯牛奶吗
Lucia: Yuxuan, do you want to drink plain milk?
Alice: 这眼镜有点松
Alice: These glasses are a bit loose.
Lucia: 还是你还喝你刚才的咖啡哦
Lucia: Or do you want to continue with your coffee?
Katrina:  不用我就喝我自己这个就行
Katrina: No, I'll just drink my own.
Lucia: 好的好的
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 那我们就三个杯子哎
Lucia: Then we’ll just use three cups.
Lucia: 那牛奶可能稍微有点多
Lucia: So the milk might be a bit much.
Alice: 没事喝不完可以给我
Alice: It's fine, if there's any left, give it to me.
Lucia: 啊可以哈哈你可以等他凉了再喝
Lucia: Ah, sure, haha, you can drink it when it cools down.
Lucia: 或者我们多喝一点
Lucia: Or we can just drink more.
Alice: 没事没事
Alice: It's fine, it's fine.
Alice: 我只是比较喜欢喝凉的
Alice: I just prefer drinking it cold.
Lucia: 我和薇薇多喝一点
Lucia: I'll drink more with Tasha.
Lucia: 因为那个靖康他好像也要喝咖啡
Lucia: Because Jingkang also wants to drink coffee.
Tasha:  OK第二次做的是薄饼
Tasha: OK, the second time we made pancakes.
Alice: 你你那个离他远一点
Alice: Move that a bit farther away.
Alice: 因为怕熏到你的眼镜
Alice: So it doesn't smoke your glasses.
Tasha:  颠勺颠勺
Tasha: Flip the pan, flip it.
Alice: 哎哎小心点小心点啊
Alice: Hey hey, be careful, be careful.
Tasha:  我靠太可怕了
Tasha: Oh my god, that's so scary.
Lucia: 哦我在把我手机的
Lucia: Oh, I'm turning on my phone's
Lucia: 铃声打开
Lucia: ringtone.
Lucia: 要不然一会万一外卖到了的话
Lucia: Otherwise, if the delivery arrives,
Lucia: 我听不见
Lucia: I won't hear it.
Tasha:  熟了吗熟了好像
Tasha: Is it done cooking? It seems like it is.
Lucia: 我昨天的那个卡让我放哪去了
Lucia: Where did I put that card from yesterday?
Alice: 哎小心点怎么了
Alice: Hey, be careful. What's going on?
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Tasha:  没事
Tasha: Nothing.
Alice: 咋了我看看
Alice: What happened? Let me see.
Tasha:  锅溅油了
Tasha: The oil splashed from the pan.
Tasha:  这真是一个脾气不好的锅
Tasha: This pan has such a bad temper.
Alice: 可以等油没那么热的时候就放进去
Alice: You can put it in when the oil isn't so hot.
Tasha:  我关小火了他还是崩了
Tasha: I turned down the heat, but it still splashed.
Alice: 油太热的那啥嗯
Alice: The oil is too hot, so...
Alice: 因为我们那个面粉里有含水吗
Alice: Because our flour contains some moisture.
Tasha: 含
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 应该好了别烧的时间太久给他烧开了
Lucia: It should be done. Don't cook it for too long or it'll boil over.
Alice: 筷子竟然不是一样长的
Alice: The chopsticks are not the same length.
Alice: 这就顺眼了
Alice: Now they look right.
Alice: 露西亚你把它拿起来一下
Alice: Lucia, can you pick it up for a moment?
Alice: 因为这个桌布应该不耐高温
Alice: Because this tablecloth isn't heat-resistant.
Lucia: 把这个稍微往中间放一点
Lucia: Move this a bit to the center.
Lucia: 啊不过一会中间还要放蛋饼
Lucia: Oh, but we need to put the omelet in the center later.
Lucia: 也不需要那么中间放一会吧
Lucia: So we don't need to move it too much to the center for now.
Lucia: 然后把这边上稍微挪一下
Lucia: Then adjust this side a little bit.
Tasha:  哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 这是你的咖啡吗
Lucia: Is this your coffee?
Alice: 我已经倒进去了
Alice: I already poured it.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 那这个应该是刚才给靖康拿出来的
Lucia: Then this one must be the one we took out for Jingkang.
Lucia: 给他放回去
Lucia: Let's put it back for him.
Lucia: 他一会下来了再拿吧
Lucia: He can take it when he comes down later.
Lucia: 要不然东桌上东西太多了
Lucia: Otherwise, the table will be too cluttered.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Okay.
Lucia: 这个放走
Lucia: Move this away.
Alice: 很棒
Alice: Great.
Tasha:  已经与他和平相处了
Tasha: I've already made peace with him.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha:  我说已经与他和平相处了
Tasha: I said I've already made peace with him.
Alice: 那我帮你把这个洗了吧
Alice: Let me wash this for you.
Alice: 给你做收尾工作
Alice: I'll finish up for you.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  这也挺简单
Katrina: This is pretty simple too.
Katrina: 多长2分
Katrina: How long? 2 minutes?
Katrina: 我们当时是跳另一个版本
Katrina: We were doing another version at that time.
Katrina:  好像幼儿园舞蹈
Katrina: Feels like a kindergarten dance.
Katrina:  好啊哈哈
Katrina: Yeah, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 对这个这个音乐比较比较比较可爱
Lucia: Yeah, this music is quite cute.
Katrina:  当时跳的是哪个来着
Katrina: Which one were we dancing to again?
Katrina:  啊他们有3个
Katrina: Ah, they have three.
Katrina:  这个有一点点慢我看看
Katrina: This one is a bit slow, let me see.
Katrina:  一会变成操了
Katrina: It'll turn into exercise soon.
Katrina:  等我给你看我跳了几个然后你看一下
Katrina: Let me show you a few moves and you can check it out.
Katrina:  哎这个
Katrina: Hey, this one.
Tasha:  喂
Tasha: Hello?
Tasha:  啊不用接听
Tasha: Ah, no need to answer it.
Katrina:  2345刚好5个人
Katrina: 2, 3, 4, 5, just right, 5 people.
Katrina:  这节奏比刚刚那个快一点
Katrina: This rhythm is a bit faster than the previous one.
Katrina:  那个就四拍动作太慢
Katrina: The other one with four beats was too slow.
Lucia: 这个音乐真的好幼儿园
Lucia: This music really feels like kindergarten.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  但只有这种就大家都能都听过的音乐
Katrina: But it's only these kinds of music that everyone knows.
Katrina:  才能
Katrina: That can...
Katrina:  不行这个不太
Katrina: No, this one is not quite right.
Alice: 关火了吗
Alice: Did you turn off the stove?
Tasha: 没呢
Tasha: Not yet.
Alice: 翻面了吧该
Alice: Should we flip it over?
Tasha:  嗯我看一下
Tasha: Hmm, let me check.
Lucia: 哎还是比较合适是的
Lucia: Hey, this one fits well.
Katrina:  这怎么没有齐舞了又
Katrina: Why is the group dance missing again?
Lucia: 后面这段的音乐好像
Lucia: The music in the latter part seems...
Katrina:  但是他齐舞不多
Katrina: But there aren't many group dances.
Katrina:  我再找一个叫什么奔跑的青春
Katrina: Let me find another one called "Running Youth."
Katrina:  这也还行你看啊
Katrina: This one's pretty good too, look.
Lucia: 我我投这个一票
Lucia: I'll vote for this one.
Lucia: 我觉得这个鼓点强一些
Lucia: I think this drumbeat is stronger.
Katrina:  嗯嗯但这这个怕他们有点学不会
Katrina: Yeah, but I'm worried they might not be able to learn this.
Katrina:  动作还挺多
Katrina: There are quite a lot of moves.
Katrina: 这确实好看哈哈哈
Katrina: This does look good, haha.
Lucia: 对而且这个鼓点强一些
Lucia: Yes, and this drumbeat is stronger.
Lucia: 就是他这个节奏其实更好
Lucia: Actually, this rhythm is better.
Katrina:  嗯那我们看能不能扣个几分
Katrina: Hmm, let's see if we can deduct a few points.
Katrina:  扣个1分多
Katrina: Deduct over a point.
Lucia: 或者可以把就是难度高一点的动作
Lucia: Or we can remove the more difficult moves.
Lucia: 给他删掉
Lucia: Just delete them.
Katrina:  改了
Katrina: Changed.
Lucia: 对重新编一下
Lucia: Yes, re-choreograph it.
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Sure.
Lucia: 我们可以从这段开始
Lucia: We can start from this part.
Lucia: 我觉得这对
Lucia: I think this is right.
Lucia: 然后这个就是前面出现过的那一部分
Lucia: Then this part appeared earlier.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 就是可以省略掉一些
Lucia: We can skip some parts.
Lucia: 就是比较强那个什么的
Lucia: The stronger parts.
Alice: 我拿个充电宝
Alice: I'll get a power bank.
Alice: 我怕这个没电
Alice: I'm afraid this will run out of battery.
Alice: 充电宝在哪里嘞
Alice: Where's the power bank?
Tasha:  要不要喊他一起吃
Tasha: Should we ask him to join us for dinner?
Alice: 浩然刚好像看他出去了还是怎样
Alice: Haoran seemed to have gone out or something.
Katrina:  哎那就前边
Katrina: Oh, then the front part.
Katrina:  刚前面的
Katrina: Just the front part.
Lucia: 突然breaking了起来哈哈
Lucia: Suddenly started breaking, haha.
Katrina:  对要不就前面1分半看看
Katrina: Yeah, maybe just see the first one and a half minutes.
Alice: 差不多关了
Alice: Almost done.
Katrina:  感觉1分多够拍
Katrina: One minute should be enough.
Katrina:  哈哈够够呛
Katrina: Haha, maybe not enough.
Tasha:  谁用碗喝咖啡呢
Tasha: Who drinks coffee with a bowl?
Alice:我
Alice: Me.
Tasha:  aha
Tasha: aha.
Tasha:  好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Katrina:  到底在哪跳啊
Katrina: Where exactly are we dancing?
Katrina:  外面还是二楼啊
Katrina: Outside or on the second floor?
Lucia: 可能是外面吧
Lucia: Probably outside.
Lucia: 但是其我在想是外面没有什么舞台
Lucia: But I think there's no stage outside.
Katrina:  外面是石子哎
Lucia: 然后二楼又不够宽敞
Lucia: 如果我们五六个人的话不是很宽敞
Katrina:  我看看
Katrina:  外面还是石子哎那只能在这跳
Katrina:  那天就可以在这跳
Katrina:  然后他们坐这坐坐这
Lucia: 队形变化
Lucia: 上面就大家就一直站着
Lucia: 不要变队形了就就排好哈哈
Katrina:  这不用编队形啊
Katrina:  就在这啊
Jake: 这是舞台
Katrina:  这是舞台
Katrina:  因为二楼太小了嘛
Katrina:  那肯定晚上跳舞在外面跳
Katrina:  这石子哎刚好就在这
Jake: 哦
Lucia: 但我感觉这里这也只能站平着站
Katrina:  哎只有5个人撒开
Lucia: 我们没法前后站人
Lucia: We can't have people standing in front and behind.
Lucia: 对吧我感觉
Lucia: Right, I feel that way.
Katrina:  2个差不多最
Katrina: Two people should be enough.
Jake: 下面也站几个
Jake: Let's have a few stand below.
Katrina:  多站两排吧
Katrina: Let's make two rows then.
Jake: 下面站几个会摔着吗
Jake: Will it be safe to have people standing below?
Katrina:  可以前三后二这种
Katrina: We could do three in front, two in back.
Lucia: 下面下面不能站对
Lucia: No, no one should stand below.
Jake: 不能站人
Jake: No one can stand there.
Lucia: 下面不好跳
Lucia: It's hard to jump from below.
Katrina:  前三后二那种
Katrina: Three in front, two in back then.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 前三后二也可以
Lucia: Three in front, two in back works too.
Katrina:  还行动作幅度小
Katrina: It also keeps the movements small.
Lucia: 对就是
Lucia: Right, exactly.
Lucia: 可以不用
Lucia: We don't need to...
Lucia: 就是整个就是怎么形容的
Lucia: Like, how do I put this...
Lucia: 就是他这个队列间间距不用很大
Lucia: The spacing between the rows doesn't need to be big.
Lucia: 就是可能前三个人稍微往前点
Lucia: Maybe the front three can move forward a bit.
Lucia: 后两个人稍微往后一点点
Lucia: And the back two can move back a little.
Lucia: 就是一点1.5排的那种那种间距就可以了
Lucia: Just a 1.5 spacing will do.
Katrina:  哦这可以晒衣服
Katrina: Oh, we can dry clothes here.
Jake: 挺好这边再搞一个舞台幕布
Jake: Nice, let's put up a stage curtain here.
Lucia: 啊可以把投影搬到外面来吗
Lucia: Ah, can we move the projector outside?
Jake: 不是就是一个幕
Jake: No, it's just a curtain.
Jake: 嗯布就是真实的physical的一个布
Jake: Yeah, like a real physical curtain.
Katrina:  那你得买一个这种
Katrina: Then you need to buy one like this.
Jake: 在这一挂
Jake: Hang it here.
Jake: 对这布以前买过挺多
Jake: Right, I used to buy a lot of these curtains.
Jake: 20多块钱一个
Jake: About 20 bucks each.
Jake: 这么大的
Jake: This big.
Katrina:  可以可以量一下
Katrina: Sure, let's measure it.
Lucia: 像影像那个影棚的那种吗
Lucia: Like those in a photo studio?
Katrina:  网上找吗
Katrina: Find it online?
Jake: 对就是广告打广告
Jake: Yeah, for advertising.
Tasha:  啊你结束了
Tasha: Ah, you're done?
Jake: 那个村门口的那种大广告你知道吗
Jake: Those big ads at the village entrance, you know?
Alice: 哈哈对
Alice: Haha, yes.
Lucia: 哦哈哈哈哈可以
Lucia: Oh, hahaha, that's good.
Jake: 哦哈哈哈可以
Jake: Oh, hahaha, that's good.
Lucia: 我们可以想想
Lucia: We can think about it.
Katrina:  吃吧吃吧
Katrina: Let's eat, let's eat.
Lucia: 上面要什么花纹或者颜色的
Lucia: What pattern or color do you want on it?
Jake: 这什么曲子呀
Jake: What song is this?
Katrina:  奔跑的青春
Katrina: Youth Running.
Katrina:  哈哈但是还没决定好几个
Katrina: Haha, but we haven't decided on a few yet.
Katrina:  还要看一下大家难度
Katrina: Need to check everyone's difficulty level.
Katrina:  尝尝
Katrina: Try it.
Katrina:  猪猪侠那个有点慢
Katrina: Pig Hero is a bit slow.
Katrina:  拿筷子了吗
Katrina: Got chopsticks?
Katrina: 12345
Katrina: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Jake: 我又被diss了
Jake: I'm being dissed again.
Jake: 你又diss我哈哈
Jake: You're dissing me again, haha.
Jake: 总不回他的消息
Jake: Always ignoring his messages.
Jake: 他让我吃早饭
Jake: He wants me to have breakfast.
Jake: 牛啊就喊牛
Jake: Just calling him "cow."
Tasha:  这还牛哦别看了
Tasha: This is impressive, don't look anymore.
Tasha:  哈哈哈这锅烧导热性太好
Tasha: Hahaha, this pot conducts heat too well.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哦导多了
Jake: Oh, too much heat.
Lucia: 我觉得这一看就很好吃
Lucia: I think this looks really delicious.
Jake: 是啊我不会
Jake: Yeah, I won't.
Tasha:  不不会
Tasha: No, you won't.
Jake: 为啥不会就会
Jake: Why won't you? You can.
Lucia: 这个牛奶是你的了
Lucia: This milk is yours.
Tasha:  我没有信心
Tasha: I have no confidence.
Alice: 没事没事
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 试试试试
Jake: Give it a try, give it a try.
Lucia: 然后如果需要加咖啡请自行加
Lucia: And if you need to add coffee, please add it yourself.
Lucia: 因为我不知道你要喝多浓
Lucia: Because I don't know how strong you want it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 好没关系
Jake: Okay, no problem.
Tasha:  加糖
Tasha: Add sugar.
Alice: 给你露西亚你的碗
Alice: Here you go, Lucia, your bowl.
Jake: 糖在哪
Jake: Where's the sugar?
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice: 我拿一下吧
Alice: Let me grab it.
Tasha:  糖糖糖蘸糖
Tasha: Sugar, sugar, dip in sugar.
Lucia: 这个碗
Lucia: This bowl.
Lucia: 少一个没事我再拿一个好了
Lucia: It's okay if one is missing, I'll just grab another one.
Alice: 我我不要
Alice: No, I don't want it.
Alice: 我的已经结束了
Alice: Mine is already done.
Lucia: 啊啊
Lucia: Ah, ah.
Alice: 我碗都刷完了
Alice: I've already washed my bowl.
Lucia: 那我就先拿走一个这个
Lucia: Then I'll just take this one for now.
Katrina:  我不用加糖
Katrina: I don't need to add sugar.
Alice: 拿个纸擦一下
Alice: Grab a tissue to wipe it.
Alice: 放放这个放糖吧
Alice: Put it, put the sugar in.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 要什么纸
Jake: What tissue do you need?
Alice: 这这里面不是放糖蘸的吗
Alice: Isn't this where you put the sugar to dip?
Alice: 还是自己倒自己碗里
Alice: Or just pour it into your own bowl?
Tasha:  这是自己的碗
Tasha: This is your own bowl.
Katrina:  自己倒自己碗里吧
Katrina: Just pour it into your own bowl.
Alice: 谁的碗
Alice: Whose bowl is it?
Katrina:  没人用就给他吧
Katrina: If no one uses it, give it to him.
Jake: 好干不干
Jake: Is it dry or not?
Alice: 你自己倒吧要不
Alice: Why don't you pour it yourself?
Alice: 我不知道你要多少
Alice: I don't know how much you want.
Alice: 你说停吧
Alice: Just tell me when to stop.
Jake: 我我我来倒就好
Jake: I'll pour it, it's fine.
Tasha:  怎么拿了这么多筷子
Tasha: Why did you take so many chopsticks?
Katrina:  还有一个舞其实
Katrina: There's also a dance actually.
Jake: 为什么倒不下来
Jake: Why won't it pour out?
Alice: 因为他有点受潮了
Alice: Because it's a bit damp.
Tasha:  这是绵白糖本来就这么绵
Tasha: This is powdered sugar, it's supposed to be like this.
Jake: 哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake: 买的好挺好
Jake: Good purchase, really good.
Alice: 哦天哪跟谁
Alice: Oh my gosh, with who?
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh my.
Alice: 分点吧
Alice: Share some.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 强行售卖
Jake: Forced selling.
Tasha:  哎哈哈
Tasha: Hey, haha.
Alice: 你不得你给他弄碎点
Alice: You have to crush it a bit.
Jake: 强行售卖
Jake: Forced selling.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is it okay?
Tasha:  好谢谢
Tasha: Yes, thanks.
Lucia: 这个里面就应该有糖的吗
Lucia: There should be sugar in this, right?
Jake: 还要吗
Jake: Do you want more?
Alice: 蘸糖吗
Alice: Dip in sugar?
Tasha:  不是哈哈
Tasha: No, haha.
Jake: 分点
Jake: Share some.
Alice: 江苏人的
Alice: From Jiangsu.
Jake: 分分你一点
Jake: I'll share some with you.
Lucia:  呃也可以
Lucia: Uh, sure.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 你这个倒太多了
Lucia: You poured too much.
Tasha:  对他倒太多了哈哈
Tasha: Yeah, he poured too much, haha.
Katrina:  跳yes ok也行
Katrina: Dancing, yes, okay, that's fine.
Jake: 对都都都是
Jake: Yeah, it's all fine.
Jake: 是我放太多了
Jake: I poured too much.
Alice: 你要糖吗雨轩
Alice: Do you want sugar, Yuxuan?
Tasha:  然后嗯贴面蘸
Tasha: Then, um, dip it.
Jake: 要吗好
Jake: Do you want it? Okay.
Katrina:  我不要糖
Katrina: I don't want sugar.
Jake: 你也不要
Jake: You don't want it either?
Alice: 我不吃糖
Alice: I don't eat sugar.
Alice: 我会流鼻血
Alice: It makes me get nosebleeds.
Jake: 啊确实
Jake: Ah, indeed.
Katrina:  这舞也行
Katrina: This dance is okay too.
Lucia: 这个好像是我们那校庆
Lucia: This seems like our school anniversary.
Katrina:  我高中跳过
Katrina: I danced this in high school.
Katrina:  高中晚会跳过
Katrina: At the high school party.
Lucia:  虽然我觉得动作可能不完全一样
Lucia: Though I think the moves might not be exactly the same.
Lucia:  但就这个背景音乐
Lucia: But the background music is the same.
Katrina:  这个其实还行
Katrina: This is actually okay.
Katrina:  如果你能接受奔跑的青春的话
Katrina: If you can accept the running youth.
Katrina:  那你更加能接受这个
Katrina: Then you can accept this even more.
Katrina:  慢一点动作更简单
Katrina: Slower moves are simpler.
Katrina:  猪猪侠
Katrina: Pig Hero.
Lucia: 就这个也可以
Lucia: This one is also okay.
Lucia:  这个鼓点也比较清晰
Lucia: The beat is also quite clear.
Lucia: 就我喜欢这种
Lucia: I like this kind.
Lucia: 我能很快找到他的节奏的
Lucia: I can quickly find its rhythm.
Alice: 充电宝在哪
Alice: Where's the power bank?
Alice: 我这个可能快快要充电了
Alice: I might need to charge soon.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:  别把我的充电宝拔走了
Tasha: Don't take my power bank.
Alice: 你告诉我在哪我去拿就行了
Alice: Just tell me where it is, I'll get it.
Jake: 我我来拿我来拿
Jake: I'll get it, I'll get it.
Alice: 味道怎么样
Alice: How does it taste?
Tasha:  我觉得用错面团了啊面粉了
Tasha: I think we used the wrong dough, or flour.
Jake: 密度刚好
Jake: The density is just right.
Jake: 这这个面的密度刚好
Jake: This, the density of this dough is just right.
Jake: 这是你的吗
Jake: Is this yours?
Jake: 这是这是这是
Jake: This is, this is, this is...
Jake: 这是啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice: 这个不知道谁的
Alice: I don't know whose it is.
Alice: 这不是他的
Alice: This isn't his.
Alice: 他的是个小蝴蝶
Alice: His has a small butterfly.
Jake: 这啥啊
Jake: What is this?
Alice: 不对小翅膀
Alice: No, a small wing.
Jake: 怎么看呢
Jake: How do you see?
Alice: 不知道这是谁的
Alice: I don't know whose it is.
Lucia: 是我的吗
Lucia: Is it mine?
Jake: 是露西亚
Jake: It's Lucia's.
Alice: 啊姜
Alice: Ah, ginger.
Jake: 这这是姜
Jake: This, this is ginger.
Jake: 哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 嗯是
Lucia: Yeah, it is.
Jake: 这是姜
Jake: This is ginger.
Jake: 哦哦哦哦哦哦好好
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay.
Jake: 那你要点
Jake: So you want some?
Jake: 你也要点
Jake: You want some too?
Jake: 就先放这些
Jake: Just put these in first.
Katrina:  我觉得跳那个
Katrina: I think jumping that one...
Katrina:  不如跳这个
Katrina: ...isn't as good as jumping this one.
Alice: 味道还行吗
Alice: Does it taste okay?
Tasha:  啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  这还能3分钟呢
Katrina: We still have 3 minutes left.
Katrina:  这这动作都重复了
Katrina: These moves are all repeating.
Jake: 行这个比较明显
Jake: Okay, this one is more obvious.
Jake: 正好你坐着
Jake: Just sit right there.
Katrina:  哦我要充电是吗
Katrina: Oh, do I need to charge?
Jake: 可以充一会
Jake: You can charge for a while.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 是不不够啊
Jake: Is it not enough?
Katrina:  有一种机器人被连上电的感觉
Katrina: Feels like a robot getting plugged in.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 连上之后记忆加速
Jake: Once plugged in, memory speeds up.
Jake: 1秒学舞
Jake: Learn dance in 1 second.
Katrina:  激活激活了正好
Katrina: Activated, activated, just in time.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 这是谁的
Jake: Whose is this?
Tasha:  这个特别好吃
Tasha: This one is really tasty.
Jake: 哈哈哈我
Jake: Hahaha, mine.
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 我的是吧嗯
Jake: It's mine, right?
Jake: 真的吗
Jake: Really?
Tasha:  真的这是第
Tasha: Really, this is the...
Tasha:  一个成果
Tasha: ...first result.
Jake: 真的哦真吃了
Jake: Really? Oh, you ate it.
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈吃呗
Katrina: Hahaha, just eat it.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 假吃了还能
Lucia: Fake eating still works.
Tasha:  别吃了吧哈哈
Tasha: Don't eat it, haha.
Jake: 刚刚那个猪猪侠是怎么跳的
Jake: How did that Piggy Warrior dance go again?
Jake: 我很好奇
Jake: I'm really curious.
Katrina:  猪猪侠特别简单
Katrina: The Pig Hero dance is super easy.
Katrina:  就1234才做一个动作
Katrina: It's just 1, 2, 3, 4 and then you do one move.
Lucia: 对这个比较简单哦
Lucia: Yeah, this one is pretty simple.
Katrina:  可以适合你们男生跳
Katrina: It’s suitable for you guys to dance.
Jake: 好好哎这个看一下
Jake: Okay, okay, let’s check it out.
Katrina:  你看猪猪侠
Katrina: Look at the Pig Hero.
Lucia: 她的节奏节奏感没有那么
Lucia: The rhythm is not that...
Katrina:  很简单吧
Katrina: It’s very simple, right?
Jake: 嗯确实有点呆
Jake: Yeah, it’s a bit stiff.
Lucia: 那我们可以像雨轩说的
Lucia: We can do what Yuxuan said.
Lucia: 然后跳这个
Lucia: And then dance to this.
Jake: 可以都可以
Jake: Sure, that works.
Katrina:  其实都可以
Katrina: Actually, anything works.
Katrina:  一人带个蘑菇头跳那个蘑菇蘑菇
Katrina: Everyone can wear a mushroom hat and dance the mushroom dance.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 啊哈哈
Lucia: Ahaha.
Lucia: 很有道理
Lucia: That makes sense.
Katrina:  嗯买两个头套就行就不用统一服装了
Katrina: Yeah, just buy two headpieces, no need for matching outfits.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sounds good.
Katrina:  偶像玩玩岁其实也很好看我看看
Katrina: Playing with idol props is also nice. Let me see.
Jake: 买个那那种气球
Jake: Buy one of those balloons.
Katrina:  有造型的气球吗
Katrina: Are there shaped balloons?
Jake: 风吹起来
Jake: Let the wind blow it.
Katrina:  哦哦哦那个风吹那个人那个的
Katrina: Oh, the wind-blown person thing.
Lucia: 嗯是外卖到了吗
Lucia: Hmm, is the delivery here?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 不是外卖美团买药
Lucia: It’s not food delivery, it’s Meituan delivering medicine.
Tasha:  点外卖了哦
Tasha: Ordered food delivery, huh?
Jake: 来了
Jake: It’s here.
Jake: 嗯嗯好
Jake: Yeah, yeah, okay.
Tasha:  嗯我以为午饭到了
Tasha: Hmm, I thought lunch was here.
Lucia: 喂你好
Lucia: Hello, hi.
Jake: 嗯嗯哼哼哼
Jake: Yeah, yeah, mm-hmm.
Lucia:  呃我们是黄色铁门吗
Lucia: Uh, we have a yellow iron gate, right?
Katrina:  他就在这
Katrina: He’s right here.
Katrina:  我听到他声音了
Katrina: I can hear him.
Katrina:  他就在这
Katrina: He’s here.
Lucia: 哦这样子
Lucia: Oh, got it.
Lucia: 呃应该是同一个
Lucia: Uh, it should be the same one.
Lucia: 您稍等一下
Lucia: Please wait a moment.
Katrina:  我们是蓝绿色的
Katrina: We are blue-green.
Lucia: 是一个蓝绿色的建筑
Lucia: It's a blue-green building.
Alice: 薇薇这个饼你还满意吗
Alice: Tasha, are you satisfied with this pancake?
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Tasha:  嗯煎的有点
Tasha: Hmm, it's a bit overcooked.
Alice: 还不错吧
Alice: Not bad, right?
Tasha:  你吃了吗
Tasha: Have you tried it?
Alice: 没有啊
Alice: Not yet.
Tasha:  你还挺好的
Tasha: You're doing pretty well.
Alice: 那就行很棒
Alice: That's good, great.
Tasha:  可见其实什么面粉并不重要
Tasha: Actually, the type of flour doesn't really matter.
Tasha:  那个锅的问题
Tasha: It's the pan that's the problem.
Alice: 过筛也可没没关系
Alice: Sifting it doesn't matter either.
Tasha:  那个锅的问题
Tasha: It's the pan that's the problem.
Jake: 你耳朵怎么这么好
Jake: How come you have such good hearing?
Jake: 还是隔音太差了
Jake: Or is the soundproofing too poor?
Katrina:  哈哈哈我刚以为你房间有人说话
Katrina: Hahaha, I just thought someone was talking in your room.
Jake: 哦是这样
Jake: Oh, I see.
Jake: 怎么去郑州
Jake: How do you get to Zhengzhou?
Tasha:  哎你怎么是吧
Tasha: Hey, how come...
Jake: 你刚刚打电话说的
Jake: You just mentioned it on the phone.
Jake: 去干嘛呀
Jake: What are you going to do there?
Alice: 跟我约会
Alice: Going on a date with me.
Jake: 哦可以
Jake: Oh, okay.
Katrina:  你要去郑州吗
Katrina: Are you going to Zhengzhou?
Tasha:  对
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  你去郑州干啥开会吗
Katrina: What are you going to Zhengzhou for, a meeting?
Tasha:  去玩五一
Tasha: Going there for the May 1st holiday.
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Jake: 五一去郑州
Jake: Going to Zhengzhou for May 1st?
Jake: 可以人会很多吧
Jake: There will be a lot of people, right?
Alice: 啊你去郑州
Alice: Ah, you're going to Zhengzhou?
Alice: 不是你郑州去哪啊
Alice: Where exactly in Zhengzhou?
Tasha:  不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Katrina:  哈哈哈我有个舍友也是郑州
Katrina: Hahaha, I have a roommate from Zhengzhou too.
Alice: 你去
Alice: Are you going?
Lucia: 本地人
Lucia: Local person.
Alice: 你问我吧问我吧
Alice: You should ask me, ask me.
Tasha:  哦问我吧
Tasha: Oh, ask me then.
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha:  我不知道去哪呢还
Tasha: I don't know where to go yet.
Tasha:  他们安排我
Tasha: They arranged it for me.
Tasha:  我可是个P人
Tasha: I'm just a nobody.
Alice: 我的天啊
Alice: Oh my god.
Tasha:  我我跟着走
Tasha: I'll just follow along.
Alice: 我觉得去哪玩我都理解不了
Alice: I don't understand where to go for fun.
Lucia: 哈哈哈嘉怡
Lucia: Hahaha, Jiayi.
Alice: 带你去洛阳
Alice: I'll take you to Luoyang.
Lucia: 我只有碰到比我更P的朋友的时候
Lucia: I only make plans when I meet friends who are worse at planning than me.
Lucia: 我才会做计划
Lucia: That's when I plan.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈你去洛阳跟开封都挺近的
Alice: Hahaha, Luoyang and Kaifeng are very close.
Alice: 从郑州东站出发哈哈哈
Alice: Start from Zhengzhou East Station, hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈郑州最好玩的就是郑州东站
Katrina: Hahaha, the best part of Zhengzhou is Zhengzhou East Station.
Alice: 郑州东站哈哈
Alice: Zhengzhou East Station, haha.
Katrina:  买一张票去别的地方
Katrina: Buy a ticket to somewhere else.
Jake: 好啊
Jake: Alright.
Alice: 我跟你说一家
Alice: Let me tell you a place.
Alice: 超级好吃的那种甜水铺你可以去
Alice: There's a super tasty dessert shop you can go to.
Tasha:  啊你说吧
Tasha: Ah, go on.
Tasha:  我让万一我不去他们能吃
Tasha: Even if I don't go, they can still eat.
Alice: 我觉得那一栋楼只有
Alice: I think in that building, only a few shops are still open.
Alice: 就是为数不多的几家活着
Alice: There are just a few that are still alive.
Tasha:  你说
Tasha: Go ahead.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake: 这个咖啡我是怎么搞啊
Jake: How do I make this coffee?
Alice: 直接啊浓缩液倒进去往上拔
Alice: Just pour the concentrate in and pull it up.
Katrina:  就一条拔出来
Katrina: Just pull one out.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Alice: 就是大上海城
Alice: It's the Big Shanghai Mall.
Jake: 有点多哎
Jake: That's a lot.
Katrina:  不多倒进来就这么一点点
Katrina: Not much, just a little bit.
Tasha:  大上海城然后呢
Tasha: Big Shanghai Mall, then what?
Alice: 东东鲜芋圆
Alice: Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls.
Katrina:  它非常浓郁
Katrina: It's very rich.
Alice: 东西南北的东
Alice: Dong as in east.
Tasha:  东东鲜芋圆好了
Tasha: Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls, got it.
Alice: 嗯东东鲜芋圆就他们家巨好吃
Alice: Yeah, Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls, their stuff is super delicious.
Alice: 你会发现
Alice: You'll find
Alice: 那个商城基本上是倒闭的状态
Alice: that the mall is basically in a state of closure.
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 哎
Alice: Oh
Alice: 你五一要真的去的话你可以来我家玩
Alice: If you're really coming over during May Day, you can come to my place.
Alice: 真的你要不住我家吧
Alice: Seriously, why don't you stay at my place?
Katrina:  节省了一笔房费
Katrina: That'll save you some hotel money.
Alice: 真的你要不住我家吧
Alice: Seriously, you should stay at my place.
Alice: 我家也没啥人
Alice: There aren't many people at my place.
Jake: 你你还能带几个人
Jake: How many people can you bring?
Jake: 哈哈哈住几个人
Jake: Hahaha, how many people can stay?
Tasha:  能住几个哈哈
Tasha: How many can stay, haha.
Alice: 啊哈啊你有几对
Alice: Ah, how many pairs do you have?
Lucia: 对我这离你家很近
Lucia: Actually, my place is very close to yours.
Lucia: 我也可以住两个人吧
Lucia: I can also host two people.
Tasha:  我天呐哈哈
Tasha: Oh my gosh, haha.
Alice: 来吧来吧
Alice: Come on, come on.
Alice: 你你们有几个人
Alice: How many of you are there?
Lucia: 一只手
Lucia: One hand.
Tasha:  应该是3个到4个
Tasha: Probably three to four.
Tasha:  呃 4个到5个吧
Tasha: Uh, four to five maybe.
Alice: 啊把我第
Alice: Oh, I'll be
Alice: 赶出家门
Alice: kicked out of my own house.
Tasha:  啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈嗯
Tasha: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Alice: 让他让他不许回来
Alice: Let him, let him not come back.
Alice: 然后就可以腾出来房间住了
Alice: Then we can free up some rooms.
Tasha: 4 月18号8点开始抢票
Tasha: Tickets go on sale at 8 AM on April 18th.
Tasha:  怎么什么都要抢好烦啊
Tasha: Why does everything need to be fought over, it's so annoying.
Jake: 五一要抢票是吧
Jake: You need to fight for tickets on May Day, right?
Jake: 完了五一那会儿我回新加坡
Jake: Oh no, I'll be in Singapore during May Day.
Jake: 是不是特别贵
Jake: Is it very expensive?
Jake: 呵呵呵我没订票
Jake: Haha, I haven't booked my ticket yet.
Katrina:  还没订票
Katrina: You haven't booked it yet?
Jake: P人不会订票
Jake: P people don't know how to book tickets.
Jake: 哈哈哈我可以讲你之前的那个故事
Jake: Haha, I can tell you about your previous story.
Alice: 我五一要回家了
Alice: I'm going home for May Day.
Lucia: 你可以讲你之前的那个故事
Lucia: You can tell your previous story.
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice: 我现在还没开始定
Alice: I haven't started booking yet.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈连我一个P人都觉得震惊
Lucia: Haha, even I, just an average person, am shocked.
Tasha:  什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 呵呵我上了飞
Jake: Haha, I got on the plane.
Jake: 先去飞机场再买票
Jake: Go to the airport first, then buy the ticket.
Katrina:  嗯我是受不了
Katrina: Hmm, I can't take it.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Alice: 啊什么
Alice: Huh, what?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because...
Tasha:  先去飞机场再买票
Tasha: Go to the airport first, then buy the ticket.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Huh?
Jake: 因为这比较省钱
Jake: Because it's cheaper this way.
Tasha:  真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 因为如果我提前买票通常赶不上飞机
Jake: Because if I buy the ticket in advance, I usually miss the flight.
Jake: 所以就要改签
Jake: So, I have to reschedule.
Alice: 原来是这样
Alice: Oh, I see.
Alice: 我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Katrina:  但是你到那买不是很贵吗
Katrina: But isn't it more expensive to buy it there?
Katrina:  有的时候那个票
Katrina: Sometimes the ticket...
Jake: 但是我每次都赶不上飞机
Jake: But I always miss the flight.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Alice: 是原来是这样
Alice: Oh, I see.
Katrina:  受不了你了真的
Katrina: I can't stand you, really.
Jake: 对所以比较省钱
Jake: Yeah, so it's cheaper this way.
Alice: 这是能说的吗
Alice: Can you even say that?
Alice: 给外国人一点震撼哈
Alice: That's quite shocking for foreigners.
Katrina:  嘿嘿嘿
Katrina: Hehehe
Alice:笑死
Alice: That's hilarious.
Jake: 这个可以说吧
Jake: You can say that, right?
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Tasha: OK
Jake: 以前试了很多次教训
Jake: I've tried many times before.
Jake: 就是每次都可能提前40分钟check in
Jake: Usually, I have to check in 40 minutes early.
Jake: 然后我可能就3938分钟到
Jake: But I might arrive at 39 or 38 minutes.
Jake: 然后呵呵呵
Jake: And then, haha...
Jake: 就很失望
Jake: It's very disappointing.
Jake: 以后就不买票了
Jake: So, I don't buy tickets in advance anymore.
Alice: 呵我第一次听说
Alice: Haha, this is the first time I've heard that.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 是不是很让人震惊
Lucia: Isn't it shocking?
Alice: 我觉得我已经很很那啥了
Alice: I think I'm already quite, quite...
Jake: 哎露西你这个关了
Jake: Hey Lucia, you turned it off.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Jake: 是哎为什么会关
Jake: Yeah, why did it turn off?
Alice: 嗯充电
Alice: Hmm, charging.
Lucia: 有充着电呢
Lucia: It's being charged.
Jake: 看一下看一下
Jake: Check it, check it.
Jake: 什么什么
Jake: What, what?
Tasha:  说不出话来
Tasha: I'm speechless.
Tasha:  还是钱太多了还是还是钱太多了
Tasha: Is it because there's just too much money, or is it because there's just too much money?
Jake: 哈哈哈太多了
Jake: Hahaha, too much.
Alice: 震惊了
Alice: Shocked.
Lucia: 他被你吓着了
Lucia: He got scared by you.
Jake: 不是没有
Jake: No, not really.
Jake: 还是要省钱
Jake: Still need to save money.
Tasha:  还是钱太多了家里
Tasha: There's still too much money at home.
Jake: 还是不能白花钱
Jake: Still can't waste money.
Jake: 就是可以贵一点
Jake: It can be a bit expensive.
Jake: 但是不能白花钱
Jake: But can't waste money.
Tasha:  还是家里钱太多了
Tasha: There's still too much money at home.
Katrina:  笑死我了
Katrina: Laughing to death.
Lucia: 他又变白了
Lucia: He turned pale again.
Lucia: 但是我没有关
Lucia: But I didn't turn it off.
Lucia:  我的嗯嗯哦
Lucia: My, uh, oh.
Tasha:  啊哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia:  关闭了吗
Lucia: Did it turn off?
Tasha:  接完接电话是不是会自动关
Tasha: Does it turn off automatically after a call?
Lucia: 会影响
Lucia: It affects it.
Jake: 应该不会
Jake: It shouldn't.
Lucia:  哎他好像真的刚才那圈突然掉线了
Lucia: Hey, it seems like it really disconnected just now.
Lucia: 那我再来一个
Lucia: Let me try again.
Alice: 喂喂你们那个规划我真的很好奇
Alice: Hey, hey, I'm really curious about your plan.
Alice: 我也想知道郑州有啥玩的
Alice: I also want to know what's fun in Zhengzhou.
Tasha:  不知道呀玩啥呀
Tasha: I don't know, what's fun?
Katrina:  看下外地人做的攻略你就知道
Katrina: Check out guides made by tourists, and you'll know.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha:  不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Tasha:  我什么都不知道
Tasha: I don't know anything.
Tasha:  就今天打电话说去郑州玩嘛
Tasha: So today they called and said they want to go to Zhengzhou for fun.
Tasha:  哈哈我说有空我就去
Tasha: Haha, I said if I'm free, I'll go.
Alice: 是不是你们要去演唱会之类的
Alice: Are you guys going to a concert or something?
Tasha:  是吗
Tasha: Really?
Alice: 是吗我不知道啊
Alice: Really? I didn't know that.
Tasha:  不知道呀
Tasha: I didn't know either.
Katrina:  你怎么不来武汉玩
Katrina: Why don't you come to Wuhan for fun?
Tasha:  武汉
Tasha: Wuhan?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Tasha:  没有人邀请我去哈哈哈啊
Tasha: No one invited me to go, hahaha.
Katrina:  觉得武汉还是我邀请你
Katrina: I think Wuhan is better, let me invite you then.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Katrina:  武汉比郑州好玩一点点
Katrina: Wuhan is a bit more fun than Zhengzhou.
Lucia: 我还没去过郑州
Lucia: I've never been to Zhengzhou.
Tasha:  我也没有去过
Tasha: Me neither.
Katrina:  武汉但是武汉五一人应该很多
Katrina: But Wuhan will be crowded during May Day.
Alice: 来吧来找我吧
Alice: Come on, come visit me!
Alice: 我五一应该在家
Alice: I'll be home during May Day.
Tasha:  哈哈真的
Tasha: Haha, really?
Alice: 我也没开始订票
Alice: I haven't even started booking tickets.
Alice: 我一看那个票售罄了
Alice: I saw the tickets are sold out.
Alice: 然后我还没开始订
Alice: So I haven't started booking yet.
Lucia:  行那果然是全员P人
Lucia: So it's true, everyone is a last-minute planner.
Alice: 无所谓反正
Alice: Doesn't matter anyway.
Alice: 嗯买不到票就只能
Alice: If I can't get a ticket, then...
Lucia: 我也经常会提前两三天才订
Lucia: I also often book tickets two or three days in advance.
Lucia: 但是嗯您知道吗哈哈哈
Lucia: But, you know, hahaha.
Jake: 一般大概也就提前两个小时对
Jake: Usually, it's about two hours in advance, right?
Lucia: 比较厉害比较厉害
Lucia: That's impressive, really impressive.
Jake: 就提前两个小时就能有飞机
Jake: Just two hours in advance and you can get a flight.
Alice: 第一次听说
Alice: First time hearing this.
Alice: 真的闻所未闻
Alice: Really unheard of.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 到了机场一看那个板我觉得这个不错
Jake: I get to the airport, see the board and think, "This looks good."
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 看看多少钱
Jake: Check the price.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈闻所未闻
Alice: Hahahaha, really unheard of.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 大开眼界
Lucia: Eye-opening.
Alice: 我觉得
Alice: I think
Alice: 我提前一两天买票已经挺极限了
Alice: Buying tickets one or two days in advance is already pushing it.
Alice: 就是别人可能他一放票
Alice: Like, others might start buying tickets as soon as they are released
Alice: 或者说是提前几天就是放票的
Alice: Or a few days in advance when tickets are released
Alice: 提前几天
Alice: A few days in advance
Alice: 可能就一共推往前推个一二十天
Alice: Maybe they push it back by ten or twenty days
Alice: 就开始抢了
Alice: And start grabbing them.
Alice: 然后我大学的时候也是
Alice: Back in college, too,
Alice: 他们都已经开始想
Alice: They had already started thinking
Alice: 哪天抢哪天的票了
Alice: About which day to snatch tickets for which day.
Alice: 然后每次都是快回家了
Alice: Every time, just before going home,
Alice: 我想要不看看票吧
Alice: I thought, why not check for tickets?
Alice: 一看啊售罄哈哈哈
Alice: And then I saw, oh no, sold out! Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈是
Jake: Haha, right.
Jake: 是有一次我回家飞南京然后
Jake: There was this one time I was flying back home to Nanjing,
Jake: 就没赶上嘛
Jake: And I missed the flight.
Jake: 自然而然没有赶上
Jake: Naturally, I missed it.
Jake: 呃那一天最后
Jake: That day, the last
Lucia: 哈哈哈这个是我最爱
Lucia: Hahaha, I love this.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈自然而然没赶上
Alice: Hahahahahaha, naturally missed it.
Tasha: 自然而然没赶上
Tasha: Naturally missed it.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake: 对自然而然没有赶上
Jake: Yeah, naturally missed it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 所以所以那天看的最后一班
Jake: So, I caught the last flight that day.
Jake: 回中国了
Jake: To China.
Jake: 先到了成都
Jake: First to Chengdu.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 对到了成都待了一晚上
Jake: Yeah, stayed in Chengdu for a night.
Jake: 我觉得成都到南京应该高铁也挺快
Jake: I thought the high-speed train from Chengdu to Nanjing would be quick.
Tasha:  然后也没赶上
Tasha: And I missed it again.
Katrina:  很很远很远
Katrina: It's really, really far.
Katrina:  1,800公里
Katrina: 1,800 kilometers.
Jake: 对我我我以为挺快的
Jake: Yeah, I thought it would be fast.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 因为我想北京也挺
Jake: Because I thought Beijing was also quite
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 就差不多距离吧
Jake: About the same distance, right?
Jake: 对吧大概有几个小时
Jake: Probably a few hours.
Tasha:  啊然后赶上好吗
Tasha: Ah, then catch up, okay?
Jake: 结果要那个是飞机场买的所以
Jake: So it turns out it was bought at the airport
Jake: 赶上哈哈哈哈
Jake: Catch up, hahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Jake: 就是去到成都之对那
Jake: So we went to Chengdu
Jake: 那个是买到了成都之后
Jake: We bought it after arriving in Chengdu
Jake: 一晚上就在这个春熙路晃悠了一晚上
Jake: We wandered around Chunxi Road for one night
Jake: 然后因为第二天早上的飞机
Jake: Because the flight was early the next morning
Jake: 然后就飞走了
Jake: Then we flew out
Jake: 原来想坐高铁的
Jake: Initially, we thought of taking the high-speed train
Jake: 结果
Jake: But
Jake: 那个高铁大概也得七八个小时是吧
Jake: The high-speed train takes about seven or eight hours, right?
Katrina:  没有高铁
Katrina: There's no high-speed train
Katrina:  成都到武汉都要9个小时
Katrina: It takes nine hours from Chengdu to Wuhan
Katrina:  武汉到南京还要2 3个小时
Katrina: And another 2-3 hours from Wuhan to Nanjing
Alice: 它那个线路不一定
Alice: The route isn't always the same
Katrina:  但是但是10小时以上应该是要
Katrina: But it should take more than 10 hours
Katrina:  我同学一般都是买的飞机票
Katrina: My classmates usually buy plane tickets
Katrina:  我当时也以为
Katrina: I also thought
Katrina:  我以为那个武汉长沙
Katrina: I thought Wuhan and Changsha
Katrina:  成都是挨在一起的
Katrina: and Chengdu were close to each other
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know
Katrina:  武汉跟长沙只有一个小时
Katrina: It's just one hour from Wuhan to Changsha
Katrina:  但是到到川渝那就很远
Katrina: But it's very far to Sichuan-Chongqing area
Katrina:  就要6个小时
Katrina: It takes 6 hours
Jake: 要绕一圈
Jake: You have to make a detour
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Jake: 我也觉得应该挺近
Jake: I also thought it should be close
Jake: 我也觉得这个中国高铁应该没这么
Jake: I thought China's high-speed rail shouldn't be that
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right
Jake: 哈哈哈没这么慢
Jake: Hahaha, not that slow
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Jake: 我高铁有十几个小时
Jake: My high-speed rail took over ten hours
Lucia: 居然成都到武汉比成都到北京还慢
Lucia: It's surprising that it takes longer to get from Chengdu to Wuhan than from Chengdu to Beijing
Lucia: 总感觉好像
Lucia: It always feels like
Lucia: 感觉上应该就是他到北京更远一些
Lucia: It feels like Beijing is farther
Alice: 现高铁是不是降过速了
Alice: Did the high-speed rail slow down?
Lucia: 成都到北京应该是8个多小
Lucia: Chengdu to Beijing should be over 8 hours
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah
Alice: 现在高铁是不是降过速了
Alice: Have they slowed down the high-speed rail now?
Katrina:  这舞呢
Katrina: And the dance?
Alice: 现在一般都300多了
Alice: Now it's generally over 300.
Jake: 对都是300对
Jake: Yeah, it's all over 300.
Alice: 嗯都是300多
Alice: Yeah, all over 300.
Jake: 300整怎么
Jake: How about exactly 300?
Tasha:  太离谱了
Tasha: That's ridiculous.
Tasha:  他帮我找出来了北京到郑州的公交票
Tasha: He found me a bus ticket from Beijing to Zhengzhou.
Alice: 啊
Alice: What?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Jake: 倒多少趟
Jake: How many transfers?
Alice: 告诉我哈哈
Alice: Tell me, haha.
Tasha:  我说我说如果我不去
Tasha: I said, I said if I don't go...
Tasha:  我说我说如果我24号去北京
Tasha: I said, I said if I go to Beijing on the 24th...
Tasha:  我他说不去打死我
Tasha: He said if I don't go, he'll kill me.
Alice: 不去打死
Alice: If you don't go, he'll kill you.
Tasha:  我说住哪
Tasha: I said where will I stay?
Tasha:  然后他说麻麻利利的把公交票订下来
Tasha: Then he quickly booked the bus ticket.
Tasha:  哈哈啊
Tasha: Haha, yeah.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈你朋友是真人吧
Lucia: Hahaha, is your friend for real?
Alice: 啊我的天
Alice: Oh my god.
Jake: 北京任意点
Jake: Any point in Beijing.
Katrina:  不是怎么坐公交来这啊
Katrina: How do you take a bus to here?
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Tasha:  北京任意点到郑州
Tasha: Any point in Beijing to Zhengzhou.
Lucia: 可以坐公交去郑州
Lucia: You can take a bus to Zhengzhou.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice: 我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Tasha:  上门接送
Tasha: Door-to-door service.
Lucia: 上门接送
Lucia: Door-to-door service.
Jake: 哈哈上
Jake: Haha, yes.
Katrina:  我去
Katrina: Oh my.
Alice: 我的天呐哈哈哈
Alice: Oh my god, hahaha.
Katrina:  这是什么新的服务
Katrina: What kind of new service is this?
Jake: 专车是吧
Jake: A special car, right?
Jake: 专车才280
Jake: A special car is only 280.
Lucia: 对我也想问
Lucia: Yeah, I want to ask too.
Lucia: 这么便宜
Lucia: So cheap.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice: 比我高铁还便宜
Alice: Cheaper than my high-speed train.
Alice: 但是时间太长了屁股要坐烂了
Alice: But it's too long, my butt would be sore.
Tasha:  10个小时
Tasha: 10 hours.
Tasha:  唉那好吧
Tasha: Well, okay then.
Lucia: 在国内也没必要做什么Flex 8
Lucia: No need to take something like Flex 8 within the country.
Tasha:  9.5个小时
Tasha: 9.5 hours.
Lucia: 或者会所
Lucia: Or some club.
Lucia: 巴士这种东西
Lucia: Or a bus.
Tasha:  到那再说开宾馆
Tasha: We'll figure out the hotel when we get there.
Alice: 我看看
Alice: Let me see.
Alice: 绝了
Alice: Amazing.
Alice: 不是他是怎么能想到这条路的
Alice: How did he even think of this route?
Alice: 我真是闻所未闻
Alice: I've never heard of it.
Tasha:  他一会让我骑自行车过去哈哈哈
Tasha: He'll have me bike over there, haha.
Alice: 你骑个小黄
Alice: You'll ride a Nicous.
Lucia: 救命
Lucia: Help!
Jake: 北京到郑州自行车骑多久
Jake: How long would it take to bike from Beijing to Zhengzhou?
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Huh?
Tasha:  不知道
Tasha: No idea.
Lucia: 到地了饭就是
Lucia: By the time we get there, the food would be...
Jake: 就是五一
Jake: Just in time for May Day.
Lucia: 当地的小黄接收站都不接收
Lucia: Local Nicous stations won't even take it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, right.
Alice: 调度费太贵了哈哈
Alice: The dispatch fee is too expensive, haha.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:  那我要用那种第一次的手机号去注册
Tasha: Then I'd have to register with a new phone number.
Tasha:  然后他说新人首次可以免费调度
Tasha: He said the first-time users get free dispatch.
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你可以每路上
Lucia: You could on every trip.
Lucia: 每到一个城市换一辆小黄
Lucia: Change to a new Nicous in every city.
Lucia: 而这个城市之间还比较错
Lucia: And the cities are pretty close.
Tasha:  不是你在思考这件事的可行性吗
Tasha: Are you seriously considering this?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha:  我到那要不要先治腿
Tasha: Should I get my legs treated first when I get there?
Alice: 为了盘醋包了盘饺子
Alice: Made dumplings just to go with vinegar.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 太好笑了
Alice: So funny.
Lucia: 为了保证你能顺利去郑州玩
Lucia: To make sure you can go to Zhengzhou smoothly
Alice: 闻所未闻
Alice: Unheard of
Jake: 导航郑州哪个医院好
Jake: Navigate to the best hospital in Zhengzhou
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哪个医院好
Lucia: Haha, which hospital is good
Jake: 骨科
Jake: Orthopedics
Tasha:  我懂了就这样子
Tasha: I get it, just like that
Tasha:  我在中途然后摔倒了
Tasha: I fell halfway through
Tasha:  然后郑州开救护车过来接我哈哈哈
Tasha: Then Zhengzhou sent an ambulance to pick me up, haha
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 哎压住了谁手机
Alice: Hey, who's phone is being pressed
Alice: 郑州确实有
Alice: Zhengzhou does have
Alice: 骨科医院
Alice: an orthopedic hospital
Alice: 离东站不是很远
Alice: It's not far from the East Station
Alice: 可以到了直接去哈哈
Alice: You can go there directly, haha
Lucia: 也不用去宾馆了哈哈
Lucia: No need to go to a hotel then, haha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Tasha:  五一
Tasha: May Day
Jake: 五一
Jake: May Day
Jake: 五一放几天
Jake: How many days off for May Day
Alice: 没看
Alice: Haven't checked
Jake: 7天吧
Jake: 7 days, right?
Lucia: 5天调休5天应该是
Lucia: 5 days, plus 5 days adjusted
Alice: 休不够就请假
Alice: If it's not enough, just take leave
Tasha:  你你
Tasha: You, you
Lucia: 我们还可以大胆一点休不够就翘课
Lucia: We can be bolder, if it's not enough, just skip class
Tasha:  对啊我今天就翘课了
Tasha: Yeah, I skipped class today
Jake: 什么课啊
Jake: What class?
Tasha:  什么课不重要
Tasha: What class doesn't matter
Tasha:  我其实没见过他呢哈哈
Tasha: I actually haven't met him yet, haha
Alice:你要跳舞吗
Alice: Do you want to dance?
Jake: 好多人啊哈哈哈
Jake: So many people, haha
Lucia: 哈哈好多人
Lucia: Haha, so many people
Tasha:  哈
Tasha: Ha
Alice: 好多人啊
Alice: So many people
Alice: 我看最近有什么演唱会的票今天晚上可以开始抢了
Alice: I've been checking, there's a concert ticket sale starting tonight
Katrina:  这舞还行这版本
Katrina: This dance version is okay
Katrina:  一分五十六差不多
Katrina: About one minute and fifty-six seconds.
Tasha:  在北京的医院居然要抢
Tasha: You actually have to fight for appointments in Beijing hospitals.
Tasha:  抢票你知道吗
Tasha: Do you know that you have to fight for tickets?
Tasha:  是要提前7天的时候就要开始抢
Tasha: You have to start fighting for them 7 days in advance.
Lucia: 哎我明明在充电它为什么又变成低电量了呀
Lucia: Hey, I was clearly charging it. Why is it low on battery again?
Tasha:  那个医治的号
Tasha: The number for the treatment.
Jake: 那个我看一下
Jake: Let me see that.
Tasha:  挂号费咋这么贵 100块钱
Tasha: Why is the registration fee so expensive? 100 yuan.
Katrina:  啊怎么又有SOLO啊
Katrina: Huh, why is there another solo event?
Tasha:  专家号
Tasha: Specialist number.
Alice: 那专家号是会贵一点
Alice: Specialist numbers are a bit more expensive.
Jake: 呃没关系
Jake: Uh, it's okay.
Alice: 你会发现专家号也就给你诊疗个
Alice: You'll find that specialists only give you a brief consultation.
Jake: 应该
Jake: They should.
Lucia: 可是我刚戴上的时候它还有30%
Lucia: But when I first put it on, it had 30%.
Lucia: 但是中间有那么小一小段线没插
Lucia: But there was a small section of the cable that wasn't plugged in.
Alice:一 点点时间
Alice: Just for a little bit of time.
Tasha:  还有那种急诊预约挂号
Tasha: And there's even emergency appointment registration.
Lucia: 直到你把充电宝给我
Lucia: Until you gave me the power bank.
Tasha:  500块钱一个号
Tasha: 500 yuan for a number.
Lucia: 但是
Lucia: But...
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 很奇怪
Lucia: It's strange.
Jake: 我给你调个电多的
Jake: I'll get you one with more power.
Alice: 急诊
Alice: Emergency...
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice: 急诊还得预约
Alice: You even need an appointment for emergencies?
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Alice: 都急诊了为什么还要预约呢
Alice: Why do you need an appointment for emergencies?
Tasha:  就是紧急急诊预约号
Tasha: It's for urgent emergency appointments.
Lucia: 其实充电宝里面蛮多的它有97
Lucia: Actually, the power bank has a lot. It has 97.
Tasha:  500块一个人
Tasha: 500 yuan per person.
Jake: 嗯给你一个这个大的
Jake: Hmm, here's a bigger one for you.
Jake: 就是大的
Jake: It's a big one.
Alice: 暂时还没有遇到过急诊的情况
Alice: I haven't encountered an emergency situation yet.
Jake: 贵的
Jake: It's expensive.
Tasha:  我们学校
Tasha: Our school...
Tasha:  校医院挂号都一块钱
Tasha: The school hospital registration only costs 1 yuan.
Tasha:  你们学校也是是吧
Tasha: It's the same at your school, right?
Alice: 因为有补助是吧嗯
Alice: Because there's a subsidy, right? Yeah.
Lucia: 我们上医院刚开始就只要5毛钱
Lucia: When we first went to the hospital, it only cost 50 cents.
Lucia: 后来涨价到
Lucia: Later, the price increased to
Jake: 换一个
Jake: Change it.
Lucia: 两块钱好过分了
Lucia: Two yuan, that's too much.
Tasha:  那那是一块钱我
Tasha: That was one yuan, I...
Jake: 对要保证上面的灯一直是亮着的
Jake: Yes, make sure the light above stays on.
Jake: 他才能充
Jake: Only then it can charge.
Alice: 张惠妹
Alice: A-Mei.
Tasha:  然后每次开的药都需要提个麻袋去
Tasha: And every time the prescribed medicine needs to be carried in a big bag.
Tasha:  去提是吧
Tasha: To carry it, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈是吧
Lucia: Haha, right?
Tasha:  他给你开药都是10盒起开
Tasha: They always prescribe at least 10 boxes of medicine.
Lucia: 对是的
Lucia: Yes, exactly.
Lucia: 我们校医院也开挺多的
Lucia: Our school hospital also prescribes a lot.
Lucia: 没有这么夸张
Lucia: But not that exaggerated.
Tasha:  这没有那么夸张吗
Tasha: Isn't that exaggerated?
Tasha:  我每次
Tasha: Every time...
Lucia: 你是使用了夸张的修辞手法吗
Lucia: Are you using hyperbole?
Tasha:  哈哈没有使用夸张手法
Tasha: Haha, no exaggeration.
Tasha:  我比如说呃我最近有点感冒
Tasha: For example, if I have a cold recently,
Tasha:  他会给我开说哪里感冒
Tasha: they will ask where I feel cold.
Tasha:  你喉咙疼不疼
Tasha: Do you have a sore throat?
Tasha:  我如果说喉咙疼
Tasha: If I say my throat hurts,
Tasha:  他会给我开喉咙疼的药
Tasha: they will prescribe throat medicine.
Tasha:  喷喉咙的药
Tasha: Throat spray medicine.
Tasha:  感冒灵颗粒解毒胶囊
Tasha: Cold granules and detox capsules.
Tasha:  哈哈开到一盒一种药就要开两三盒
Tasha: Haha, for each type of medicine, they prescribe two or three boxes.
Tasha:  那种可能就就不要钱吧
Tasha: Maybe those don't cost anything, right?
Lucia: 哦这个居然是2万毫安
Lucia: Oh, this one is actually 20,000mAh.
Tasha:  然后他就一直开
Tasha: And they keep prescribing.
Jake: 头疼医脑
Jake: Treat a headache with brain medicine.
Lucia: 头疼医全身
Lucia: Treat a headache with whole body medicine.
Jake: 嗯哈哈
Jake: Mhm, haha.
Alice: 今年没有抢到一张票
Alice: Didn't get a single ticket this year.
Jake: 抢什么票
Jake: What tickets?
Tasha:  抢什么票
Tasha: What tickets?
Alice: 演唱会的一张没抢到
Alice: Not a single concert ticket.
Katrina:  我都找代抢了我自己真抢不到
Katrina: I even hired someone to buy for me, couldn't get any myself.
Lucia: 让
Lucia: Let...
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah
Lucia: 让杨老板用他的那些设备帮你抢
Lucia: Let Jake use his equipment to help you.
Tasha:  设备帮你抢
Tasha: The equipment to help you.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Alice: 啊可以吗
Alice: Oh, really?
Tasha:  开启加速器
Tasha: Turn on the accelerator.
Jake: 开启7台电脑
Jake: Turn on 7 computers.
Katrina:  要搞一个Python脚本才行
Katrina: You need to write a Python script.
Lucia: 是因为他电脑多了
Lucia: Is it because he has a lot of computers?
Lucia: 因为他电脑多吗所以可以
Lucia: Because he has a lot of computers, so he can do it?
Jake: 哈哈哈一样的
Jake: Hahaha, it's the same thing.
Jake: 那你猜这台电脑
Jake: So, guess this computer.
Jake: 就是这些电脑每一台都都是租的
Jake: All these computers are rented.
Jake: 然后租了十天
Jake: And rented for ten days.
Jake: 每一台多少钱
Jake: How much for each one?
Jake: 你猜就是十天多少钱
Jake: Guess how much for ten days?
Jake: 多少钱一台
Jake: How much for each one?
Tasha:  多少钱一台多少钱
Tasha: How much for each one, how much?
Jake: 给个数给个数字吧
Jake: Give me a number, give me a number.
Lucia: 应该不会很贵吧否则他就会买了
Lucia: It shouldn't be very expensive, otherwise he would just buy them.
Tasha:  一百块钱
Tasha: A hundred bucks.
Katrina:  我们学校竟然跳过这舞
Katrina: Our school actually skipped this dance.
Jake: 差不多我把我电脑借给你吧
Jake: Close enough, I'll lend you my computer.
Tasha:  我把我电脑借给你吧
Tasha: I'll lend you my computer.
Jake: 哈哈哈十天80啊
Jake: Hahaha, ten days for 80 bucks.
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Ah
Lucia: 10天80
Lucia: Ten days for 80.
Jake: 十天80
Jake: Ten days for 80 bucks.
Lucia: 十天80
Lucia: Ten days for 80.
Tasha:  80一天
Tasha: 80 per day.
Lucia: 他说10天80
Lucia: He said ten days for 80.
Jake: 十天一个电脑
Jake: Ten days for one computer.
Jake: 一台电脑八十
Jake: One computer for 80.
Tasha:  10天
Tasha: Ten days?
Alice: 一天8块钱吗
Alice: Eight bucks a day?
Tasha:  一天才8块钱
Tasha: Only eight bucks a day?
Jake: 对一台电脑一天8块钱
Jake: Yes, one computer for eight bucks a day.
Alice: 还挺便宜
Alice: That's pretty cheap.
Jake: 可以不租了是吧
Jake: Shouldn't rent anymore, right?
Lucia: 嗯确实很便宜
Lucia: Hmm, it is indeed very cheap.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha:  啊没有啊
Tasha: Ah, no way.
Jake: 也可以租
Jake: You can also rent it.
Jake: 是吗我今天刷到这个
Jake: Really? I saw this today.
Katrina:  今天刷的这个舞
Katrina: The dance you saw today?
Tasha:  呃
Tasha: Uh...
Katrina:  是我们计算机艺术团的还是我们学校的
Katrina: Is it from our computer art troupe or our school?
Tasha:  才80块钱10天
Tasha: Only 80 yuan for 10 days.
Katrina:  我学姐在杭州上班哈哈
Katrina: My senior works in Hangzhou, haha.
Lucia: 对我也在想居然
Lucia: Yeah, I was thinking the same thing, surprisingly.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 这正在上班
Jake: She's at work right now.
Tasha:  那我以后打游戏要不不买电脑了
Tasha: Then maybe I shouldn't buy a computer for gaming anymore.
Jake: 就是这个是上班的时候跳的
Jake: She was dancing during work.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yes.
Tasha:  去租电脑吧
Tasha: I'll rent a computer.
Katrina:  这是他那年的毕业晚会
Katrina: This was at their graduation party that year.
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  他大四我大一
Katrina: He was a senior, I was a freshman.
Jake: 哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Katrina:  居然
Katrina: Surprisingly.
Tasha:  哦垃圾电脑
Tasha: Oh, garbage computer.
Katrina:  我4年前就跳过你
Katrina: I danced with you four years ago.
Katrina:  要跳舞吗哈哈
Katrina: Wanna dance? Haha.
Lucia: 不知道问问他
Lucia: Don't know, ask him.
Tasha:  弟弟得了一个怪病
Tasha: My brother got a strange illness.
Tasha:  要来北京治
Tasha: He needs to come to Beijing for treatment.
Tasha:  他在我们县医院治不好
Tasha: He couldn't get cured at our county hospital.
Tasha:  在扬州市医院治不好
Tasha: Couldn't get cured at Yangzhou hospital.
Tasha:  在南京市医院也治不好
Tasha: Couldn't get cured at Nanjing hospital either.
Katrina:  这太难了
Katrina: That's tough.
Tasha:  然后要来北京医院寻医
Tasha: So he has to come to a hospital in Beijing.
Alice: 他怎么了
Alice: What's wrong with him?
Tasha:  他长不高
Tasha: He can't grow tall.
Jake: 长不高
Jake: Can't grow tall?
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina:  多大了
Katrina: How old is he?
Tasha:  12岁
Tasha: 12 years old.
Katrina:  那还能打生长激素呢
Katrina: He can still get growth hormone shots then.
Alice: 缺什么维生素还是什么
Alice: Is he lacking some vitamins or something?
Tasha:  可能吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Tasha:  only  1米
Tasha: Only 1 meter.
Alice: 1米1米大概
Alice: About 1 meter.
Jake: 1 米1米是多少
Jake: What's 1 meter?
Katrina:  基因突变了吗
Katrina: Is it a genetic mutation?
Alice: 这
Alice: This...
Tasha:  这
Tasha: This...
Jake: 我有卷尺
Jake: I have a tape measure.
Jake: 好哈哈
Jake: Alright, haha.
Tasha:  啊不用
Tasha: No need.
Katrina:  啊不用
Katrina: No need.
Katrina:  那确实有点啊
Katrina: That is a bit...
Katrina:  12岁就这么点高
Katrina: Only 12 years old and this short?
Tasha:  对
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  家长好着急
Katrina: The parents must be worried.
Katrina:  男生女生啊
Katrina: Boy or girl?
Tasha:  男生
Tasha: Boy.
Alice: 他弟弟哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: His little brother, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: Haha, that's clever.
Lucia: 呵呵
Lucia: Hehe.
Katrina:  哦哦我没听见前面
Katrina: Oh, I didn't catch that earlier.
Tasha:  我觉得可能是生他生的比较晚
Tasha: I think maybe he was born quite late.
Katrina:  N激素啊
Katrina: N hormone, huh?
Katrina:  就是我有一个我爸爸同事就是他
Katrina: So, my dad has a colleague who...
Katrina:  他自己那叔叔就很矮
Katrina: His uncle is really short.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: So...
Katrina:  小时候就跟他儿子打那种什么促进
Katrina: When he was young, he gave his son these growth promotion shots.
Katrina:  骨骼发育的针
Katrina: Bone development shots.
Katrina:  反正一年还要大几千块钱
Katrina: Anyway, it cost thousands of dollars a year.
Katrina:  因为怕他儿子长不高
Katrina: Because he was afraid his son wouldn't grow tall.
Katrina:  因为那叔叔也就一米六
Katrina: Because that uncle is only 1.6 meters tall.
Tasha:  刚刚说要先来测骨相
Tasha: They said they need to check the bone structure first.
Katrina:  对要测什么骨龄啊
Katrina: Yeah, they need to check the bone age.
Tasha:  看骨头还能不能再生长
Tasha: To see if the bones can still grow.
Katrina:  12岁应该还可以吧
Katrina: At 12 years old, it should still be possible, right?
Alice: 是不是还会测什么骨缝
Alice: Don't they also check the bone gaps?
Alice: 什么闭合酶之类的
Alice: Something about closure enzymes or something.
Lucia: 要测
Lucia: Yes, they do check.
Katrina:  对对对要侧着
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, they need to check those.
Lucia:  运动员也要测
Lucia: Athletes need to check too.
Lucia:  那个
Lucia: That
Lucia:  就是预测你接下来的身体发育情况
Lucia: was to predict your future physical development.
Lucia: 小时候测过
Lucia: I had it done when I was a kid.
Jake: 想当运动员
Jake: Wanted to be an athlete?
Tasha:  当上了吗
Tasha: Did you become one?
Lucia: 没有没有不是不是
Lucia: No, no, no, I didn't.
Lucia: 我其实不想当运动员
Lucia: I actually didn't want to be an athlete.
Lucia: 只是那会机缘巧合
Lucia: It was just a coincidence at that time.
Jake: 可以当运动员
Jake: You could have been an athlete.
Jake: 但是不想当
Jake: But you didn't want to be.
Tasha:  还记得小时候我们学哦
Tasha: Do you remember when we were kids and we learned
Tasha:  我上的班是什么国防班
Tasha: that I attended some kind of national defense class?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha:  就是当兵当飞行员
Tasha: It was about becoming a soldier or a pilot.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's amazing.
Lucia: 哇好厉害呀
Lucia: Wow, that's really impressive.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Tasha:  当时还有一批当飞行员的那个筛选
Tasha: At that time, there was a selection process for pilots.
Alice: 你弟弟的高度有大概吧
Alice: Your brother's height is about right, isn't it?
Tasha:  嗯当时还有一批当
Tasha: Yeah, there was a batch of
Tasha:  飞行员的筛选结果
Tasha: results for the pilot selection.
Tasha:  前一天他体检前
Tasha: The day before his medical exam,
Tasha:  我不小心把他耳朵给划破了
Tasha: I accidentally cut his ear.
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哦
Jake: Haha, oh.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake: 飞不了了
Jake: Couldn't fly anymore.
Tasha:  我还在想完了他要是飞行员不通过
Tasha: I was worried that if he didn't pass the pilot test,
Tasha:  会不会就全家要来找我麻烦
Tasha: the whole family would come after me.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha:  就是飞行员身上不是不能有伤口吗
Tasha: Pilots can't have any injuries on their bodies.
Alice: 嗯对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Tasha:  啊结果他成绩没有考过
Tasha: But he didn't pass the test anyway.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 虚惊一场
Jake: False alarm.
Lucia: 去惊一场
Lucia: False alarm.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha:  呃幸不是我的问题首先
Tasha: Uh luckily it's not my problem first of all
Jake: 对对对撇清关系撇清责任
Jake: Yeah, yeah, distance yourself from the responsibility
Alice: 飞行员还得看视力
Alice: Pilots need to have good eyesight
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Lucia: 让我来看看我们的我们的备选
Lucia: Let me take a look at our backups
Alice: 就我们那个女女的宇航员刘洋嘛
Alice: Like our female astronaut Liu Yang
Katrina:  我去这太
Katrina: Oh my, this is too
Lucia: 我们的备选舞蹈
Lucia: Our backup dance
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Katrina:  这个核心力量太吓人了
Katrina: This core strength is too scary
Alice: 他当时就是
Alice: At that time, he was
Katrina:  什么时候能跳成这样啊
Katrina: When can I dance like this?
Lucia: 他这个难度太高了
Lucia: This difficulty level is too high
Katrina:  这个是我看着玩的
Katrina: I'm just watching this for fun
Katrina:  我OK我关注up主
Katrina: Okay, I'm following this creator
Lucia: 啊好厉害
Lucia: Ah, so impressive
Katrina:  我去这就力量型爵士
Katrina: Wow, this is power jazz
Alice: 就他曾经上的那个学校
Alice: He used to attend that school
Katrina:  就这样一下我脖子咔嚓一声哈哈
Katrina: If I do this, my neck would crack, haha
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Ah
Alice: 那个那个那个那个那个宇航员
Alice: That, that, that astronaut
Lucia: 啊好厉害
Lucia: Ah, so impressive
Katrina:  嗯喜欢看一些大佬跳舞
Katrina: Hmm, I enjoy watching pros dance
Alice: 他原来就是
Alice: He used to
Alice: 上学的时候就是参加选拔吗
Alice: Participate in selections during school
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Ah
Alice: 就好多人被筛掉就是因为视力不过关
Alice: Many people were eliminated due to poor eyesight
Alice: 但是他当时视力就蛮好的
Alice: But his eyesight was pretty good at that time
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow
Katrina:  太厉害了
Katrina: So amazing
Tasha:  但是当飞行员视力都要很好
Tasha: But pilots must have excellent eyesight
Katrina:  娜娜记录
Katrina: Nana, record this
Tasha:  然后身上没有伤口
Tasha: And no scars on their bodies
Katrina:  我我看一下
Katrina: Let me check
Katrina:  你要跳舞吗或者是
Katrina: Are you going to dance or
Tasha:  我也没有通过
Tasha: I also didn't pass
Katrina:  然后跳舞嘛
Katrina: And then dance
Katrina:  跟那个偶像万万岁
Katrina: Like that idol show
Tasha:  对哦不好意思是飞行员我
Tasha: Right, oh sorry, as a pilot, I...
Jake: 对宇航员
Jake: For the astronauts.
Katrina:  还有good time
Katrina: And also "good time."
Jake: 飞行员就要这样
Jake: That's how pilots should be.
Katrina:  呃就是这个
Katrina: Uh, just this.
Katrina:  还不如good time对吧
Katrina: Isn't "good time" better, right?
Katrina:  然后猪猪侠我们排掉了
Katrina: And then we eliminated Pig Hero.
Tasha:  要不跳
Tasha: How about skipping it?
Lucia: 啊什么排除的排吗
Lucia: Huh, what do you mean by "eliminated"?
Katrina:  排除的排吗
Katrina: Do you mean "eliminated"?
Tasha:  yes OK
Tasha: Yes, OK.
Katrina:  排除了OK OK
Katrina: Eliminated, OK OK.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK OK.
Katrina:  哎我可以跳yes OK可以
Katrina: Hey, I can skip it, yes OK, that works.
Lucia: 我看一下这个版本可以吗
Lucia: Let me check if this version is okay.
Lucia: 看一下
Lucia: Take a look.
Tasha:  哈哈哈我就会一个动作
Tasha: Haha, I only know one move.
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈是吧
Tasha: Hahaha, right?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Katrina:  可以跳yes OK其实也
Katrina: It's okay to skip it, yes OK, actually.
Jake: 对很重要
Jake: Yes, it's important.
Jake: 呵这是精华是吧
Jake: Haha, this is the essence, right?
Alice: 杨超越那个是啥呀
Alice: What's that thing by Yang Chaoyue?
Katrina:  差不多跟我高中跳那个
Katrina: It's similar to what I did in high school.
Tasha:  呃我不知道哎
Tasha: Uh, I don't know.
Tasha:  创造101吗
Tasha: Produce 101?
Alice: 青春有你是谁啊
Alice: Who's in "Youth With You"?
Katrina:  我那两个分不清哼
Katrina: I can't tell those two apart, ugh.
Katrina:  那两个节目
Katrina: Those two shows.
Alice: 有没有男团
Alice: Are there boy groups?
Alice: 男团是啥
Alice: What's a boy group?
Katrina:  男团是那就是范丞丞他们出道
Katrina: Boy groups, that's where Fan Chengcheng debuted.
Katrina:  那个是什么来着
Katrina: What was that show?
Tasha:  什么也是什么
Tasha: What was that?
Alice: 哎呦我的天
Alice: Oh my god.
Tasha:  创造101吗
Tasha: Produce 101?
Tasha:  我不清楚了
Tasha: I'm not sure anymore.
Alice: 时代少年团是谁啊
Alice: Who's in the "Times Youth League"?
Katrina:  少年团是直接公司出道的
Katrina: Youth League debuted directly from the company.
Katrina:  没有选秀那个
Katrina: There was no audition show.
Katrina:  TF的那个家族
Katrina: The TF family
Tasha:  你要收回来吗
Tasha: Do you want to take it back?
Jake: 没有我就玩
Jake: No, I'll just play.
Alice: 我刚一折
Alice: I just folded it.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha:  好你最多能挑出来多少米
Tasha: Okay, how many meters can you pick out at most?
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Tasha:  我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha:  我居然也想到了这个无聊的游戏
Tasha: I actually thought of this boring game too.
Jake: 他可能这个是这个
Jake: Maybe this is just it.
Jake: 这东西的上限跟人关系不大
Jake: The upper limit of this thing has little to do with people.
Jake: 我感觉
Jake: I feel.
Tasha:  我我其实刚刚想的就是挑战一下
Tasha: I actually just wanted to challenge it.
Tasha:  最高能折多少米
Tasha: See how many meters I can fold.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:  好我们来猜一下最高还能折多少米
Tasha: Okay, let's guess the maximum number of meters we can fold.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:  谁能猜对
Tasha: Who can guess right?
Jake: 呵呵呵把这全吃了
Jake: Haha, eat it all.
Tasha:  谁要是猜错了就把这些全吃了好吧
Tasha: Whoever guesses wrong has to eat it all, okay?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Jake: 那都全吃了
Jake: Then eat it all.
Tasha:  让我看一下现在多少米了
Tasha: Let me see how many meters it is now.
Jake: 那你看啥呀
Jake: What are you looking at?
Jake: 你要猜
Jake: You have to guess.
Jake: 现在一米4243
Jake: It's 1.4243 meters now.
Tasha:  好你猜多少
Tasha: Okay, how much do you guess?
Jake: 我猜一米45
Jake: I guess 1.45 meters.
Tasha:  就是就就会折掉
Tasha: That's it, it will fold.
Tasha:  我们以那个为失败
Tasha: We'll take that as a fail.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:  让我赌一米6
Tasha: I'll bet on 1.6 meters.
Alice: 我觉得你要完了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: I think you're done for, hahahahahaha.
Katrina:  后面 4个应该都是一样的
Katrina: The last 4 should be the same.
Tasha:  啊啊那我要赌一米五
Tasha: Ah, then I'll bet on 1.5 meters.
Jake: 我也觉得你要完了啊
Jake: I think you're done for too.
Jake: 那也差不多完了
Jake: That's about it.
Tasha:  你是一米多少
Tasha: What was your guess?
Alice: 哈哈哈 1米45
Alice: Haha, 1.45 meters.
Jake: 一米一米四五
Jake: One meter, one meter forty-five.
Tasha:  那我就赌一米六
Tasha: Then I'll bet on one meter sixty.
Jake: 那你想吃你就
Jake: Then if you want to eat, you...
Alice: 没事反正哈哈
Alice: It's fine anyway, haha.
Jake: 吃吧你要不
Jake: Just eat, if you don't...
Tasha:  那我赌一米555吧
Tasha: Then I'll bet on one meter fifty-five.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 你要多少
Jake: How much do you want?
Tasha:  1米55
Tasha: One meter fifty-five.
Jake: 一米55
Jake: One meter fifty-five.
Alice: 1米55跟一米45差10公哈哈
Alice: One meter fifty-five and one meter forty-five are ten cm apart, haha.
Jake: 你你自己来你自己来一米55
Jake: You do it yourself, one meter fifty-five.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha.
Alice: 因为它越长它这个
Alice: Because the longer it is...
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 你悄悄作一下弊
Alice: You secretly cheat a bit.
Alice: 你可以把你的手往前伸一点
Alice: You can stretch your hand forward a little.
Alice: 但也伸不了多远
Alice: But you can't stretch it too far.
Tasha:  哎好了啊可恶仔
Tasha: Hey, alright, you little rascal.
Alice: 好了这才一米三多哈哈哈
Alice: Alright, it's just over one meter thirty, haha.
Jake: 挺强的
Jake: Pretty strong.
Katrina:  这个副歌跳了3遍
Katrina: This chorus was repeated three times.
Katrina:  其实他新动作不是很多哎
Katrina: Actually, there aren't many new moves.
Alice: 我给你
Alice: I'll give you...
Katrina:  你觉得呢
Katrina: What do you think?
Alice: 感觉这玩意会割伤手
Alice: I feel like this thing might cut your hand.
Lucia: 我觉得这个也可
Lucia: I think this one is also okay.
Jake: 嗯小心点
Jake: Hmm, be careful.
Katrina:  其实难度不大
Katrina: Actually, it's not that difficult.
Katrina:  我看了一下全是那个
Katrina: I looked, it's all like that.
Alice: 慢慢的
Alice: Slowly.
Katrina:  然后奔跑青春你还要再看一下吗
Katrina: And then, do you want to watch "Running Youth" again?
Alice: 有杠杆的感觉
Alice: It feels like a lever.
Katrina:  奔跑青春跳出来蛮好看的
Katrina: "Running Youth" looks pretty good when you jump out.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Alice: 没关系没关系
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina:  但是感觉只能跳一分钟
Katrina: But it feels like I can only jump for a minute.
Alice: 哎呀拉地了哈哈
Alice: Oh no, it's dragging, haha.
Tasha:  啊哈哈别
Tasha: Ah, haha, stop it.
Jake: 哈哈哈来吃开吃
Jake: Hahaha, come on, let's eat.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 这是用什么
Jake: What's this made of?
Jake: 这是加了什么别的材料吗
Jake: Did you add any other ingredients?
Jake: 面粉鸡蛋没了
Jake: Just flour and eggs, that's it.
Alice: 就糖
Alice: Just sugar.
Tasha:  面粉鸡蛋
Tasha: Flour and eggs.
Tasha:  yes
Tasha: Yes.
Jake: 嗯可以
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Jake: 这什么曲子
Jake: What's this song?
Jake: 我去小孩吗
Jake: Oh, kids?
Katrina:  奔跑的青春
Katrina: Running Youth.
Jake: 这都
Jake: They're all...
Katrina:  高中生
Katrina: High schoolers.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 我真没见过蘸白糖的吃法
Alice: I've never seen anyone eat it with white sugar.
Jake: 真的吗对那确实可能只有那一片
Jake: Really? Yeah, maybe it's only in that area.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Alice: 嗯对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 但我们那有甜豆腐脑跟咸豆腐脑
Alice: But where I'm from, we have sweet and salty tofu pudding.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:  那我们吃吃咸豆腐呢
Tasha: Then let's eat the salty tofu pudding.
Jake: 啊已经不记得了
Jake: Ah, I can't remember anymore.
Jake: 现在好像这什么店都能开
Jake: Nowadays, it seems like any kind of store can open.
Jake: 已经不知道以前是什么味儿
Jake: I can't even remember what it used to taste like.
Jake: 因为有很多外地的人吧
Jake: Because there are so many people from different places.
Jake: 所以什么味儿都有
Jake: So there are all kinds of flavors.
Katrina:  嗯跳1分半就跳1分半
Katrina: Hmm, jump for a minute and a half, then a minute and a half.
Katrina:  这1分半感觉跟那个跟3分的差不多
Katrina: This minute and a half feels like it’s about the same as three minutes.
Katrina:  我们看下yes OK吧
Katrina: Let's see, yes, okay?
Katrina:  yes OK
Katrina: Yes, okay.
Katrina:  yes OK应该也还好
Katrina: Yes, okay, it should be fine.
Katrina:  全网最详细版教程
Katrina: The most detailed tutorial on the internet.
Jake: 这后面什么字
Jake: What's written in the back?
Katrina:  喜什么什么他们工作室吧
Katrina: Like what, their studio or something?
Alice: 啥呀
Alice: What?
Jake: 这是一个团
Jake: It's a group.
Jake: 哦好吧
Jake: Oh, okay.
Katrina:  舞蹈工作室
Katrina: Dance studio.
Tasha:  狗剩子不知道
Tasha: Gousheng doesn't know.
Alice: 谁是狗剩子
Alice: Who is Gousheng?
Jake: 我们后面也放一圈
Jake: We'll put a circle behind us too.
Jake: 呵呵放一个什么呢
Jake: Haha, what should we put?
Lucia: 可以是自己设计一个logo哈哈
Lucia: We can design our own logo, haha.
Jake: 哈哈可以
Jake: Haha, sure.
Lucia: 因为每个人就是练舞的studio就会在后面放上这个
Lucia: Because every dance studio puts this at the back.
Tasha:  哈哈是吧
Tasha: Haha, right?
Tasha:  不记得了
Tasha: Don't remember.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 坐你旁边吧
Alice: Sit next to you?
Lucia: 然后每次上完课之后
Lucia: And every time after class,
Lucia: 就会有人拿那个酷炫的那个有有
Lucia: someone will take that cool, you know, gimbal camera.
Lucia: 说什么云台的相机
Lucia: And record you moving back and forth.
Katrina:  可以跳yes okay了
Katrina: You can dance "yes okay."
Lucia: 然后给你录往前往后
Lucia: And make those video effects.
Katrina:  哈哈其实可以跳yes ok了
Katrina: Haha, you can actually dance "yes okay."
Jake: 哦OK OK
Jake: Oh, OK OK.
Lucia: 然后录出那种视频的效果
Lucia: And record those video effects.
Tasha:  或者那个什么呃
Tasha: Or maybe, uh...
Katrina:  我要不发群里
Katrina: Should I post it in the group?
Katrina:  你们自己挑
Katrina: You guys pick.
Katrina:  这也好看
Katrina: This one looks good too.
Katrina:  说服一下那个修硕
Katrina: Convince Shure.
Tasha:  啊他也要跳
Tasha: Ah, he needs to dance too?
Katrina:  哈哈把他拉进来呗
Katrina: Haha, let's drag him in.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  我最喜欢看男生跳女团舞了
Katrina: I love watching guys dance girl group dances.
Jake: 他可以跳
Jake: He can do it.
Jake: 我觉得可以
Jake: I think he can.
Katrina:  他可以我觉得
Katrina: He can, I think.
Alice: 我觉得跳起来没准比我们还
Alice: I think if he dances, he might even be better than us.
Katrina:  对比我们更妖娆的有可能
Katrina: Yeah, maybe even more graceful than us.
Lucia: 确实
Lucia: True.
Alice: 还还娇羞呢
Alice: And even more shy.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Alice: 哈哈娇俏哈哈哈
Alice: Haha, so cute, haha
Tasha:  那个什么
Tasha: What's that
Katrina:  这也不是很快吗
Katrina: Isn't this also quite fast
Tasha:  afterlike afterlike
Tasha: afterlike, afterlike
Katrina:  Afterlife那是不是有点难
Katrina: Afterlife, isn't that a bit difficult
Tasha:  有点难吗
Tasha: Is it a bit difficult
Katrina:  嗯那是女团舞
Katrina: Yeah, it's a girl group dance
Tasha:  我看好多男生在网上跳那个仿舞
Tasha: I see a lot of guys doing that dance online
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha:  还有那个Dota
Tasha: And there's also Dota
Katrina:  低头吗还是什么
Katrina: Looking down, or what
Tasha:  到对头
Tasha: Exactly
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina:  低头那有点难那个
Katrina: Looking down, that's a bit hard
Tasha:  那个有点难吗
Tasha: Is that a bit hard
Tasha:  他那个节奏很简单吧
Tasha: The rhythm is quite simple, right
Lucia: 这个确实不太难
Lucia: It's actually not that hard
Katrina:  他那个跳不出那个牛津斯的感觉
Katrina: Can't really dance like New Jeans
Katrina:  这还行是吧
Katrina: This is okay, right
Katrina:  这多少 1分 43 还行
Katrina: What's the time, 1:43, not bad
Tasha:  afterlike
Tasha: afterlike
Katrina:  afterlike我看看啊
Katrina: afterlike, let me check
Alice:是不是该换水了
Alice: Is it time to change the water
Katrina:  呜呜呜哎
Katrina: Oh no
Katrina:  昨天昨天新换的
Katrina: Changed it yesterday
Katrina:  嗯afterlike好有意思天哪出道了
Katrina: Hmm, afterlike is so interesting, wow debut
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Tasha:  哒哒哒哒
Tasha: Dadadada
Katrina:  张元英的团
Katrina: Jang Wonyoung's group
Tasha:  是的
Tasha: Yes
Katrina:  这有点难
Katrina: This is a bit hard
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 啊这个有点难
Lucia: Ah, this is a bit hard
Tasha:  挑战张元英转圈舞那个
Tasha: Challenge Jang Wonyoung's spinning dance
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake: 哈哈哈可以
Jake: Hahaha, sure
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Katrina:  这是真爱豆啊
Katrina: This is a real idol
Katrina:  看张元英的
Katrina: Look at Zhang Yuanying's.
Lucia: 两天都经常跳
Lucia: She's been dancing a lot these two days.
Lucia: 很有力量才
Lucia: So much energy.
Lucia: 能跳出它这个效果来
Lucia: That's how she achieves that effect.
Lucia: 我觉得我们这几天可能排不了
Lucia: I don't think we can pull it off in the next few days.
Katrina:  呜啊啊
Katrina: Ughhh.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:  哈这要跳给谁看呢最终
Tasha: Haha, who are we dancing for in the end?
Jake: 得从健身开始
Jake: We need to start with fitness.
Lucia: 嗯呃我们
Lucia: Hmm, uh, we...
Jake: 呃呃呃
Jake: Uh, uh, uh.
Katrina:  那yes OK吧
Katrina: So, yes, OK?
Jake: 相机哎
Jake: The camera, hey.
Lucia: 可我们还不是有什么九到正无穷
Lucia: But don't we have something like nine to infinity?
Katrina:  虫子
Katrina: Bugs.
Jake: 呵呵呵对
Jake: Hehe, right.
Jake: 九到正无穷
Jake: Nine to infinity.
Tasha:  啊这么可怕
Tasha: Ah, that's so scary.
Jake: 14亿全国人民
Jake: 1.4 billion people in the country.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵不
Jake: Hehehe, no.
Alice: 能不能是全球人民
Alice: Could it be the global population?
Jake: 七十亿全球人民
Jake: 7 billion people worldwide.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 七十亿全球人民呵
Jake: 7 billion people worldwide, haha.
Katrina: 我手机呢
Katrina: Where's my phone?
Katrina:  帮我拿下手机薇薇
Katrina: Can you get my phone, Vivi?
Alice: 是这个吗
Alice: Is it this one?
Tasha:  看那个台舞吧
Tasha: Look at that stage dance.
Katrina:  我发群里看看
Katrina: I'll post it in the group.
Alice: 塔莎你在吗
Alice: Tasha, are you there?
Tasha:  yes you see you say
Tasha: Yes, you see, you say.
Jake: 像这个领域大概有有100个组
Jake: In this field, there are about 100 groups.
Jake: 100个组在做
Jake: 100 groups working on it.
Jake: 如果他们都用你们的这个数据的话
Jake: If they all use your data.
Tasha:  什么东西
Tasha: What are they?
Jake: 就至少是100个研究员
Jake: At least 100 researchers.
Jake: 他们要看你们跳舞
Jake: They want to see you dance.
Jake: 对呵呵呵呵呵对
Jake: Yes, hahaha, yes.
Lucia: 但是不是会不是会处理一下
Lucia: But won't they process it somehow?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Jake: 对对对但是是但是你们就会跳舞吗
Jake: Yeah, yeah, but can you guys dance?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake: 对没事
Jake: Yeah, no worries
Lucia: 没事他不知道是我就行
Lucia: It's fine, as long as he doesn't know it's me
Jake: 是是没问题
Jake: Yes, yes, no problem
Lucia: 不知道是我就是
Lucia: As long as he doesn't know it's me
Lucia: 其实我拍难度高的也无所谓
Lucia: Actually, I don't mind doing the difficult parts
Lucia: 就算跳砸了他也不知道是咱是吗
Lucia: Even if I mess up, he won't know it's us, right?
Katrina:  lady Candle呀
Katrina: Lady Candle, yeah
Alice: 简直不敢相信我要是跳这个舞
Alice: I can hardly believe if I danced this
Alice: 会有多扭曲
Alice: It would be so awkward
Tasha:  我靠
Tasha: Oh my god
Alice: 哈哈哈疯了吧
Alice: Hahaha, crazy, right?
Tasha:  疯了吧
Tasha: Crazy, right?
Katrina: 其实我跟你说
Katrina: Actually, let me tell you
Katrina: 张元英他们团的舞
Katrina: The dance by Jang Won-young's group
Katrina: 你看着简单
Katrina: It looks simple
Katrina: 好像没什么用力
Katrina: Like it doesn't take much effort
Katrina: 但是你跳出来很丑
Katrina: But when you do it, it looks ugly
Katrina: 你跳不出张元英那种感觉
Katrina: You can't capture Jang Won-young's vibe
Katrina: 就他们团的舞
Katrina: Their group's dance
Katrina: 我就我经常不知道怎么发力
Katrina: I often don't know how to put in the effort
Tasha:  那yes OK
Tasha: Well, yes, OK
Katrina: 就很神奇
Katrina: It's really amazing
Tasha:  确实很简单啊
Tasha: It really is simple
Katrina: 我分享到群里看看
Katrina: I'll share it in the group and see
Katrina: YES OK就跳这个
Katrina: YES OK, let's dance to this
Katrina: 跳一分多差不多
Katrina: Dancing for about a minute should be fine
Katrina: 哎他鼓点还挺强
Katrina: Hey, the beat is actually quite strong
Alice: 来我家玩吧
Alice: Come hang out at my place
Alice: 邀请你
Alice: You're invited
Tasha:  看能不能抢到医院的票
Tasha: Let's see if we can get tickets to the hospital
Tasha:  我可能五一就要跟我妈妈在北京看病
Tasha: I might have to go to Beijing with my mom for a check-up during May Day
Katrina: 叫什么来着EGO
Katrina: What's it called again, EGO?
Tasha:  life
Tasha: Life
Alice: life
Alice: Life
Katrina:  哎呀我发大群里吧万一他们还有人想跳呢
Katrina: Oh, let me post it in the big group, maybe someone else wants to dance too
Lucia: 哎可以剧组会跟我们一起跳吗
Lucia: Hey, will the crew dance with us too?
Jake:  可以跳可以跳
Jake: You can jump, you can jump.
Alice: 剧组是不是就最后一天会来
Alice: Is the crew only coming on the last day?
Jake: 呃也不是周五吧
Jake: Uh, not really, maybe Friday.
Lucia: 他们中间还会啊OK
Lucia: They will come in between too? Okay.
Jake: 周五他们上课啊
Jake: They have classes on Friday.
Alice: 今天周几周三
Alice: What day is it today? Wednesday?
Jake: 今天就会来两个
Jake: There will be two coming today.
Katrina:  good time也分享一下
Katrina: Good time, let's share it too.
Jake: 上课打卡
Jake: Clock in for class.
Jake: 呃就是紫藤唯一的女生她要打卡
Jake: Uh, Violet, the only girl in the lab, she needs to clock in.
Jake: 他们实验室要打卡
Jake: They need to clock in at the lab.
Jake: 所以不太方便来
Jake: So it's not convenient for them to come.
Jake: 周末可以来
Jake: They can come on the weekend.
Jake: 周五周六周日
Jake: Friday, Saturday, and Sunday.
Katrina:  奔跑的青春要分享吗
Katrina: Should we share "Running Youth"?
Lucia: 要不分享一下让大家看看哪个好
Lucia: How about we share it and let everyone see which one is better.
Lucia: 不过奔跑吧青春在这几个里面算比较难的一个
Lucia: But "Run, Youth" is one of the more difficult ones among these.
Katrina:  还有要给简单点的就是偶像万万岁
Katrina: We also need to give a simpler one, like "Long Live Idols".
Jake: 放到管家群
Jake: Put it in the butler group.
Jake: 管家一起跳就给你们开小车的
Jake: If the butlers jump together, we'll give you a ride.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Lucia: 欢迎
Lucia: Welcome.
Jake: 你们都做过了吗
Jake: Have you all done it?
Jake: 都做过了
Jake: All done.
Alice: 我没
Alice: I haven't.
Jake: 你还没有做哦
Jake: You haven't done it yet?
Jake: 今天给你
Jake: Today is your turn.
Jake: 今天还有一次
Jake: There's still one more today.
Alice: 但我没快递
Alice: But I don't have delivery.
Jake: 没关系今天该兜风了嘛
Jake: No worries, today we should take a ride.
Katrina:  该买嗯
Katrina: Should buy it, yeah.
Lucia: 我们如果要买东西的话得今天最晚明天得买要不然送不到
Lucia: If we want to buy something, we need to buy it today or at the latest tomorrow, otherwise, it won't get delivered.
Katrina:  得买了
Katrina: We need to buy it.
Jake: 对是的
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Katrina:  OK这4个挑吧
Katrina: Okay, let's choose from these four.
Lucia: 我都可以P人的快乐时刻就是让他用帮忙决定的
Lucia: I'm fine with any. The happy moments of P people are when they use it to help decide.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Katrina:  投票吧
Katrina: Let's vote.
Lucia: 而且因为我这几年就是我我
Lucia: And also because in these past few years, I...
Lucia: 我前两年就开始
Lucia: I started a couple of years ago...
Lucia: 跳这种
Lucia: To dance this kind of...
Jake: 哦对就是这个
Jake: Oh right, it's just this one.
Lucia: 这个是我们一个编舞
Lucia: This is one of our choreographies.
Jake: 这个没有办法一起挑
Jake: This can't be danced together.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Katrina:  什么风格
Katrina: What style?
Jake: 对嗯
Jake: Right, yeah.
Katrina:  给我看看
Katrina: Show me.
Lucia: 就是这个是前前年的一个就是编舞
Lucia: So this is a choreography from a couple years ago...
Katrina:  啊我就说你有这方
Katrina: Ah, I thought you had this style.
Katrina:  感觉你很有这个气质
Katrina: You really have the vibe.
Lucia: 对然后我之前学了一段时间hi-pop
Lucia: Yeah, and I learned hi-pop for a while before.
Lucia: 但这几年都没怎么跳了
Lucia: But haven't danced much in recent years.
Katrina:  嗯我一般跳爵士比较多
Katrina: Hmm, I usually dance jazz more.
Katrina:  有点偏民族现代
Katrina: It's a bit of ethnic and modern mix.
Lucia: 对对可能更现代舞一点
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, maybe more modern dance.
Lucia: 因为我是没做过民族这个课
Lucia: Because I haven't done ethnic dance classes.
Lucia: 我们当时是教现代舞
Lucia: We were taught modern dance back then.
Lucia: 然后所以就我直接躺下去
Lucia: So I just lay down...
Lucia: 就是老师说你们要用到快点学了之后
Lucia: The teacher said we need to learn quickly...
Katrina:  嗯嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Lucia: 然后我就躺下
Lucia: Then I lay down.
Katrina:  你这好有气质
Katrina: You have such elegance.
Katrina:  这个这个
Katrina: This, this...
Katrina:  我有点跳不来
Katrina: I can't quite dance it.
Katrina:  因为我感觉我没那么柔
Katrina: Because I don't feel that flexible.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This...
Lucia: 而且这个也不适合咱们这个场地
Lucia: And this isn't suitable for our venue.
Katrina:  对对对
Katrina: Right, right.
Lucia: 其实是我
Lucia: Actually, I...
Katrina:  我们学校办金秋舞蹈时候
Katrina: At our school's Golden Autumn Dance...
Katrina:  就全部都跳这种舞
Katrina: We all dance this kind of dance.
Alice: 可以坐我旁边吗
Alice: Can I sit next to you?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina:  跳那种讲历史的那种舞
Katrina: Dance those that tell historical stories.
Alice: 喜欢跟你在一块
Alice: I like being with you.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈可以可以
Jake: Hahaha, sure, sure.
Lucia: 其实我乱编的
Lucia: I actually made that up.
Lucia: 我们老师让每个每个同学定
Lucia: Our teacher asked each student to decide.
Katrina:  你哦你自己编的
Katrina: You mean you made it up yourself?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 我们老师让每个同学自己选一个音乐
Lucia: Our teacher asked each student to pick a piece of music.
Lucia: 然后编一段
Lucia: And then choreograph a segment.
Lucia: 然后但其实我只编了前一分半
Lucia: But I only choreographed the first minute and a half.
Lucia: 所以后一分半我就胡乱舞蹈哈哈
Lucia: So for the next minute and a half, I just improvised and danced randomly, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  心理素质好强啊
Katrina: Your mental strength is impressive.
Lucia: 哈就有点有点PPT卡拉OK那个意思
Lucia: Haha, it’s like doing a PowerPoint karaoke.
Katrina:  居然能当人的面糊了
Katrina: You actually did that in front of people.
Lucia: 后面我就开始随意发挥
Lucia: So I just started freestyling.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 把前面的东西再跳一遍
Lucia: And repeated the earlier moves.
Jake: 可以freestyle
Jake: You can freestyle.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 反正没有人知道他原本是什么样的
Lucia: Anyway, nobody knew what it was supposed to be originally.
Katrina:  我看一下如果这个只有1分多然后这个跳全曲
Katrina: Let me see if this one is just over a minute, then I'll dance the whole thing.
Alice: 这个舞我来跳
Alice: I’ll do this dance.
Alice: 不知道有多丑陋哈哈哈
Alice: Who knows how ugly it will look, hahaha.
Katrina:  这个只跳
Katrina: This one only dances...
Katrina:  1分半其他的就是跳视频里的
Katrina: A minute and a half, the rest is just following the video.
Lucia: 我前面疫情的时候就是回国
Lucia: During the pandemic, I went back home.
Lucia: 然后不是有一段时间就刚好
Lucia: And there was a period when...
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 马上就是就要结束了
Lucia: It was about to end.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 但是就是还没有
Lucia: But it hadn’t ended yet.
Lucia: 那个当时
Lucia: At that time...
Lucia: 还没有就是
Lucia: It hadn’t...